Four,
three,
two,
one,
ladies and Gentlemen,
Michael Shermer and heavens on earth.
The scientific search for the afterlife,
immortality and Utopia.
Did you find anything?
No,
sorry.
Nothing.
Well,
I found interesting journeys that people
use to try to get there from both the
religious perspective and the scientific
perspective.
Um,
so I do deal with the monotheisms
versions of the afterlife and heaven,
you know,
Judaism,
Christianity and Islam.
But the core of the book is the radical
life extension is crayons,
transhumanist,
the Extropians,
the mind up loaders,
the people that take all the supplements
and all of the whole range there.
I find that incredibly interesting.
They call it an afterlife or atheists.
It is,
right?
Yeah.
I mean when,
when you think about some of the people
that are really like over the top hope,
did you go to that 20,
45 thing in New York a few years back?
There was a futurist convention with all
these people that for whatever reason
they have this arbitrary date of 20,
45 years.
It's been getting pushed back.
This is when the singularity come,
he's going to cut,
was 20 slash 30,
then 20,
40 now 45.
Um,
Kurzweil Kurzweil big.
He's like the Grand Poobah.
He is no download it.
And when he gets on stage now he's not
Predator naturally dynamic like a
preacher,
but he starts talking about,
you know,
we're gonna get to live forever.
You're going to have your mind uploaded.
And people are just like,
oh my God,
we are the generation that's going to do
it.
This is the first time.
And the mom,
you know,
I used to be religious in my youth and I
thought,
man,
this is like being back in church again.
She stopped being religious.
Uh,
I started in high school and stopped in
graduate school,
so it was much seven.
You started being religious in high
school,
so it wasn't something that your family
introduced.
My parents were pretty secular.
They,
they weren't antireligious at what?
That wasn't a thing then,
but this is 1971 when I was in high
school and the,
and the sort of nascent born again
movement was starting and there was no
religious affiliation.
It was just like,
it's me and Jesus,
that's it.
It's just you and the Lord.
There's a lot of these,
um,
very charismatic hip,
young preachers that are doing sort of a
thing like that where they don't even
have their own church to like rent time
and the church and they have these
meetings where it's not,
it's just nondenominational and they
just talk about God and yet they get a
lot of people fired up.
Yep.
And you know,
they,
the place I went to this place called
the barn in Locker Santa where I grew up
in,
you know,
they played guitar and sang to a sex
cult.
It was kind of only starts banging.
I was hoping for something like that.
But no,
no,
no.
That,
that,
that is one of the problems with the
utopia that 19th century utopian
experiments,
they always turned into this,
you know,
free sex for the leader.
Well,
it always seems like whenever there's a
man that's in a position where people
start worshiping,
you know,
and then they start hanging on his every
word.
He's like,
start you gotta.
Start fucking some of these people.
Well,
I do,
I covered Jim Jones and uh,
you know,
the way I phrase it is that no one joins
a cult.
They join a group that they think is
going to do good,
save the world can help me improve my
life,
improve the lives of others.
And there's pictures online.
You can see if Jim Jones with Jerry
Brown,
governor Jerry Brown first round and you
know,
they were man in the soup kitchens.
He was very liberal,
open to African Americans being part of
the church in San Francisco.
They're gays women.
Uh,
you know,
it was a really cutting edge,
pioneering thing at the time it seemed
like,
yeah,
that,
that's a cool thing.
I'm going to join this group.
Not that me,
but you know,
the people that did this in the fifties
and sixties when he was coming up and
then into the seventies and then,
then,
yeah,
he started having sex and drugs and then
the,
you know,
the feds started kind of poking around
taxes and that's when they went to South
America speaking,
which I think this week is the spike
special.
It's now the paramount network on Waco.
Waco,
this isn't that right now.
I think it's like a started Sunday.
Yeah.
I think it's a six part series or
something along those lines.
See,
that's an interesting.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm absolutely convinced most of these
guys believe what they say now.
Maybe,
maybe they're bullshitters at the start
or they only partially believe,
but they,
they repeat the rhetoric.
Their followers give them positive
reinforcement.
They come to believe it.
And uh,
you know,
David Koresh,
he was right down the barrel.
He totally believed,
willing to die for his beliefs and he
also was having sex with everybody.
I mean,
it's so common.
It's almost cliche.
And his ex girlfriend grew up in one of
these sort of religious cults and it was
the same deal.
The head guy was having sex with all the
women and you know,
he would have sex with different
people's wives and everybody had a lead
them.
Yeah.
Say there was a fundamentalist Mormons.
Um,
what's his name that's in jail now?
Jeff.
Jeffrey.
Jeff,
Jeffrey,
Steve Jeffries.
It is.
I'm thinking of Jim Jefferies,
my friend,
the comedian.
But anyway,
yeah,
that's,
you know,
that's how it gets corrupted.
I don't know if you've ever read John.
I'm John Crack hours book under the
banner of Heaven.
This is the guy that,
that mountain climber that did a into
thin air and,
and uh,
and the,
um,
the one about the Alaskan kid.
Anyway,
he wrote this book called under the
banner of the kid who died.
Yes.
When they made that movie about moving
into the wild.
Yeah.
So he did into the wild into thin air.
Krakauer's a great writer.
So this book,
he starts to investigate the murder of
this,
um,
polygamous family in Utah,
just as a journalist.
He's going to do a story for the New
Yorker or something.
And then he realized it just takes them
down the path of this incredible world
of polygamy,
which still goes on now legally it's not
illegal,
but they marry one and then the others
are so called sister wives and they're
just there and they live on these,
in these border towns along the border
between Colorado and Utah,
like Colorado city.
You know,
I've been to some of these places.
It's like a,
it's like a twilight zone episode.
You go into this town gas station,
whatever.
It's like,
oh,
it feels kind of weird here.
And uh,
so krakauer discovered this whole world
of,
you know,
going all the way back to the founding
of the religion.
And um,
uh,
what's the name Joseph Smith and you
know,
he gets this revelation from God that,
uh,
well basically he's banging the woman
down the street,
he's married.
And so he gets this revelation from God
and crack era has this scenario in the
book where he,
he tells his wife,
now,
honey,
I've been talking to God and you're not
going to believe this,
but he says,
I have to marry this,
you know,
so,
and so down the street.
And she's like,
Oh yeah,
well I have to start seeing other guys.
No,
no.
God was very specific about this just
for the guys.
And uh,
and how do I know you talked about.
Well,
my buddies,
they were there.
They heard it also.
And this is the first page of the book
of Mormon is an affidavit.
These are the people that heard the
revelation that they all signed it and
it's like,
okay,
so this is how it starts.
When Joseph Smith started it all off in
18,
20,
he was only 14.
Yeah,
so 14 year old is not a liar.
I just learned that a lie.
It's not even like that.
They're bad people.
When you're 14 years old,
you are a developing entity.
You know your frontal lobes are not
fully formed.
You don't really know what you're
practicing sentences,
you know what you're doing,
trying to exert your influence,
and this guy was just very creative.
He was and he got chased out of Palmyra.
New York is where he started and then he
moved to Missouri when basically he was
in trouble with the law and and other
issues and then he got in trouble there
and he was killed and it usually,
this ends a cult when the leader dies.
Now there's a,
there's a,
there's a critical period if you get a
new dynamic leader to take over.
Like in the case of scientology,
David miscavige took over after l Ron
Hubbard passed over to the other side
and he managed to keep it going.
Same thing with Brigham Young.
It was bringing young that turned this
little cult into a a world religion and
they just went further west to Utah to
get away from federal authorities.
Now,
how much of a hit is scientology taking
from that?
Leah Remini?
I don't.
I've not seen any data like a
memberships and they're all secret about
that.
Anyway.
It's proprietary data,
so who knows?
I can't imagine they could survive.
Well,
they could survive because they have
tons of money through real estate
investments,
but I can't imagine their numbers or
could be doing anything but drinking.
Yeah.
Between the Lawrence Wright book than
the Hbo Documentary Feature.
The crispy and your dialogue with
Aaliyah was incredible and cheese.
Just to hero amongst secular.
Is that fight against colts?
That's really.
That's really the best way to do it.
Not top down laws against cults unless
they're doing something,
he'll obviously illegal,
but just bottom up members speaking.
I had David Miscavige has dad on as
well.
That was,
that was sad.
That was sad because I felt like I was
talking to a guy who felt like he wasted
his life and lost
his son.
Right.
And he brought his son into scientology.
The whole thing was.
That was really disturbing.
Yep.
Just A.
It's just very strange that the United
States government is allowing those
people to be tax exempt.
I mean,
with all the evidence that's available,
you just go and look at what they're
proposing and what they believe and the
fetus and the frozens entities,
they're dropped into the volcano.
All the crazy shell.
The story about there,
this is what really worried me about the
irs.
I mean,
I've always thought,
you know,
I don't fear it hell or the devil,
but I figured the irs,
you know,
I take.
I'm pretty careful about that,
but they're the only major organization
I've ever seen that beat the irs and
they did it through a thousands of
lawsuits.
I think they sued him like 3,500 times
or something and every single member
that they could get to do it to them as
well.
They were getting all their members to
suicide.
They were suing.
That was the story.
Isn't that how it worked?
Yeah.
And eventually the irs has said,
okay,
if I get your tea,
your tech.
But I mean if they're letting the
Mormons do it and why wouldn't they let
the scientists do and I really don't
think any religion.
It's ridiculous.
I agree.
I mean in 2018 with what we know about
reality,
the fact that we let some old voodoo
superstitious nonsense,
right?
Not have to pay taxes and exert extreme
power politically,
socially,
economically.
It's crazy.
Well,
so.
And they like preachers get it.
They could,
they can live in a house tax free,
then have to pay property tax on the
home that they own,
you know?
So there's a lot of these side benefits
also that you don't normally hear about.
So gross.
So the freedom from religion foundation
and some of these other organizations.
Acu trying to combat some of this,
but,
but legally,
how do you distinguish that from say a
nonprofit like doctors without borders
or one of these other groups?
That Clinton Foundation?
Yeah.
There was some statistic recently and
the Clinton Foundation,
how much money and not in 2014.
They actually donated to Cherry.
Oh Christ.
It was like six percent.
Something like extremely low.
The rest of it with payroll and.
Yeah,
mostly expenses.
Private.
They're scams.
All these things are scams.
Yeah.
It's just,
yeah,
it might be good to just clean house
and,
and just.
No one gets a nonprofit or tax free
status.
Yeah.
Unless you're just.
Well,
I don't know.
I mean I feel like there was room in the
world for compassionate charities that
are actual charities that are really
legitimate.
There's room in the world for them and I
think that they should have tax exempt
status,
but I think we should be really
stringent.
Right.
You know about what we accept.
Yeah.
Well the Supreme Court then they have a
pr problem is where do you draw the
line?
Do you know?
Because somebody says,
well,
I have a goofy belief that the Jane's
have some weird beliefs or something,
but you know,
but,
but they're man in the soup kitchens,
they're helping the poor and there's no
corruption.
So what's the difference between them
and the scientologists who say,
Hey,
you know,
we have our own religious beliefs that
to
use sound goofy,
but you know,
to us they're true.
What's the difference?
Well,
the Mormons are fascinating to me
because they do seem goofy when you look
at the idea that Joseph Smith,
who was a 14 year old found golden
tablets that contained a loss work of
Jesus and only he could read them
because he had a magic seer stone.
And then when the,
the local townspeople came to see,
well,
where are these stones?
Oh,
the angels came and took them away
because we did not believe like it's so
preposterous.
But Mormons are really nice people.
Totally Nice.
They are the best cult.
They're the sweetest,
nicest place.
I think they've made the transition from
coal to religion to a religious sect.
And most,
most Christians no longer consider them
a cult.
Some evangelicals do because they're
pretty far out,
but most mainstream Christian say,
yeah,
they're Christians.
I mean,
they accept Jesus as their savior and
that technically that gets you in the
club.
They start to let all that Joseph Smith
stuff go.
Yeah.
Because they're the way they treat
people's fantastic.
I mean,
yeah,
I'm not a big fan of them going to these
poor countries and proselytizing and you
know,
getting these vulnerable people to
become part,
but I think the way they deal with
community and the way they deal with
each other,
it's like a very.
It's a very warm and friendly and family
environment and most of the Mormons that
I've met that are practicing have been
very nice people and they're serious
about their tithing and the 10 percent.
I mean they have strict rules about this
like capital gains that it's equivalent
capital.
So if you sell your house and make a
profit,
you got to give 10 percent of that to
church,
not just your income,
your paycheck,
and they.
They're pretty,
pretty strict about that.
And the money,
as far as I know,
mostly goes for good causes that really
does help poor people,
things like that.
So in your book,
did you go over near death experiences?
I have a chapter on that.
What do you think is going on?
Like when people like the ones that have
fascinated me or people in the hospital
bed that see their body from above and
you're dealing with a bunch of chemicals
that are released in the body,
right?
There's morphine and all sorts of
different things,
psychedelic chemicals and all the
different things that are happening
while your brain is,
is basically on the edge of death,
right?
So it's important to remember that
they're near death experiences.
You're not actually dead.
So there's,
there's a luminal transitional stage
there where you're sliding into some
other state of consciousness,
altered state of consciousness.
And we know that if you inject or you
take hallucinogens,
you know those are molech.
Those are molecules that operate on a
lock and key mechanism with the synapses
in your brain and your neurons.
So if they,
these external drugs work in this
molecular lock and key mechanism,
there must be natural chemicals similar
molecularly to that in the brain already
just in smaller doses.
So one theory about near death
experiences is that a,
is that this is a way of transitioning
from living dead without feeling anxious
and falling apart and upset and
depressed or whatever.
Just kind of a smooth feel good,
you know,
better than a morphine drip kind of way
of making the transition.
And uh,
but we know for example,
that this,
a scientist named Dr James wintery
worked for the United States air force
working with pilots,
accelerating them in a centrifuge and
they would black out this part of their
training,
you know,
two g,
three G,
four g boom out you go at some point,
like 10 g's.
And most of them have these little
dream.
Let states that he called them,
which are kind of like a.
I saw a tunnel of white light at the end
of the tunnel.
I felt myself floating out of the seat
and having these sort of weird
experiences and we know exactly what
that is.
You know,
the blood is being compressed to the
center of the body,
including the center of the brain.
The last thing to go is your brainstem,
of course,
keep you alive.
So the Cortex is shutting down from the
outside in.
That would create this kind of tunneling
effect on the back of your skull,
where your visual Cortex is that create
some of that,
uh,
open brain surgeries.
These are on epileptic patients where
they cut them open and they poke around
to see where the seizures are starting.
Um,
and,
and so they could,
you know,
zap those neurons instead of some big,
crude a attack and anyway,
so while they're doing that,
they get permission from the patient to
wake them up while they're under a and
the brain is open and they tap around
with electrodes.
So this is one way to map the brain is
doing.
If so,
what do you report when I tap here?
Oh,
I just had a vision of my 10th birthday
or whatever.
And it's like,
okay,
that's where that,
that stored right there.
Well,
there's another spot right on the,
um,
the temporal lobes just above your ears
where you can tap it and the person
says,
Oh,
I'm floating out of my body.
I'm up by the ceiling now.
And you tap it a little to the left on
my left leg is up,
my right leg is that night.
My left arm is floating in.
My right arm is floating way up here
now.
Now I'm coming back down just by,
you know,
with a Rheostat,
just controlling how much electricity is
going into the neurons in that one
particular spot.
So we know for sure that the near death
experiences are in the brain and the
experiences that the people report are
real.
They have experienced,
um,
but we know it's neurologically based.
Now the counter argument is yes,
of course you have to have your brain to
have experiences,
but it's kind of a like a doors of
perception opening into this other realm
that these chemicals allow you to do.
It's like it was,
by the way,
I've been talking with Graham Hancock
about Alaska.
He's invited me to come join him and
Arrhythmia in Costa Rica to try this,
you know,
I've never tried this and I'm tempted to
go do this to say,
okay,
let's,
I'm going to write about these things.
I should experience it.
And,
but there's a debate amongst people who
do this,
that you know,
it.
Is it strictly just in your head and
you're not actually going anywhere or
does it open some door to some other
dimension?
Okay.
That's Kinda the.
And um,
and so the near death experience,
believers counter that will,
yes,
it's in your brain,
but it still is taking you somewhere
else.
The problem is,
is that how you tell the difference
between.
I had a personal experience that the
only way you can share it as if you
actually go through it yourself for a
scientific community that studies as
well.
There has to be some way to test it
somehow or tell the difference between
that.
So for example,
the limitations of the scientific method
does because we are dealing with
consciousness and you're dealing with
memories and dreams and ideas.
Like you can't measure those either.
That's right.
So,
uh,
I quote go to other sources.
Okay.
So first of all,
I discussed the most famous example is
even Alexander's a trip to have and he
wrote a book called proof of Heaven.
Now this is a harvard trained
neurologist.
He knows more about the brain than I do
and so he knows all the research I'm
talking to you about and there's a lot
more.
So.
But for him it was so powerful and okay,
what's it like?
So he talks about in his book he was in
a coma,
in a hospital.
Okay.
So he takes this trip and the colors
were unbelievably intense and rich and I
felt just deep personal love for the
people I saw in oneness with the cosmos.
And it goes on and on about this.
So then I quote from Oliver Sacks,
his memoir when the talks about in the
sixties when he was dropping acid and
you know,
the colors were incredibly intense and I
had this incredible feeling of love and
connected and I quote from Sam Harris's
the opening pages of waking up.
You know,
I took ecstasy and I'm sitting there on
the couch with my buddy and all of a
sudden I feel this intense love for my
friends.
In other words,
you know,
the narratives are indistinguishable to
an outsider.
So how do you know that you're actually
going to heaven or you're just having a
fantastic trip?
Well,
it's entirely possible.
It's both.
Well,
so how do we know?
We don't know that.
I think the real problem is people
saying that they know.
Right?
Right.
Saying that I know that I was in another
dimension.
I mean,
it's entirely possible that your
consciousness is capable of going
through these chemical doorways that are
created by these molecules and that it
experiences some frequency on the,
on the dial.
Like if there's a radio dial,
maybe we're at 95 point five,
but you can get to 97 if you take,
you know,
x amount of milligrams of diamonds,
tryptamine and then you go to this new
place.
You know,
this still physically here and Elvis
Huxley's book the doors of perception.
Yes.
Which supposedly is where the door has
got their name,
but somebody told me that that's a meme.
That's not true,
but I don't know.
Anyway,
but that's the idea.
Yeah,
sounds good.
So,
but really what you're getting at is a
super core problem of what is truth,
how do you know that it was so mystical
experiences are by definition personal
and you can't corroborate them through
some external scientific method.
So I mean science is based on the,
on the,
on the act that we can falsify a claim,
we can test it somehow and that it's not
just me pointing to something and say,
I think that's true because I
experienced that,
you know.
So I wrote a column in scientific
American about this called.
What is truth is I started off with a
lie.
The truth for me is that dark
chocolate's better than milk chocolate.
Then maybe you say no,
milk chocolate's better than dark
chocolate and then you know,
there's no way we're going to resolve
that because the truth is that that's
just preference.
That's just,
that's an internal state or I say the
other example I use is,
you know,
the stairway to heaven is the greatest
rock song of all time.
Then you go,
no,
freebird is better than stairway to.
Okay.
You can't resolve these things.
Right.
So you slide there from into things like
these personal experiences we have.
So you know,
so what I think Graham is hoping if I go
to rhythmia and try Iowaska and I say,
wow,
I report this fantastic experience I had
was literally I'll have this and then
it'll be,
we'll did I Michael Shermer go to this
other dimension and now I really kind of
as a skeptic need to renounce my pure
materialistic,
monistic a belief in,
in,
in admit there's a dualistic.
That's another side.
There's the spirit side or something and
I'm not at all sure I could do that
because how would I get out of my own
head and say,
I know for sure that I went to this
other place because I wouldn't know
you.
Most certainly don't know you,
you,
you know that the experience was a real
experience in terms of the fact that you
had it like you,
you felt the things.
I haven't done Iowasca,
but I've done the active ingredient and
Iowasca many times it's
dimethyltryptamine and it's more potent
in the form that I've done in it.
It's a shorter,
lasting,
much more potent experience and it's
undeniably phenomenal.
Really.
It is very crazy.
It's impossible to describe.
I would throw some words around and do
my best,
but it won't work.
Right.
The trip itself,
what's really bizarre,
there's a lot of really bizarre aspects
of it,
but one of the things is really bizarre
is the feeling that you've been there
before him and the speculation and
Terence Mckenna talked about this pretty
in depth.
One of the,
one of the speculations is that when
you're in rem sleep,
you're experiencing some form of dime,
Ethel tryptamine in that your brain,
your liver,
your.
They know for a fact that it's produced
by your liver and your lungs,
and now they know the used to be
anecdotal evidence that was produced by
the pineal gland,
which is of course the third eye in
reptiles and certain reptiles that
actually has a retina.
We didn't literally is in the center of
your head where the eastern mysticism
third it exists right now.
They know that in rats because of the
cottonwood research foundation,
which is something that Dr Richard,
Rick Strassman,
who was the guy who wrote the book dmt
the spirit molecule,
right?
He was the guy who got the first
federally approved tests done on
dimethyltryptamine clinic trials and uh,
it's an amazing book,
really,
really fascinating.
And he was a part of this cotton we'd
Research Foundation and they've now
proven that in live rats,
the pineal gland produces dmt.
Obviously that doesn't produce an in
people,
but it's,
it's very hopeful to.
Do you have other mammals.
Yeah.
And again,
if,
if the molecular lock and key mechanism
is set up in the brain already for this
external drug to work,
there must be something like that
already.
That's in the brain that evolved for
some reason.
Are you aware of the correlation between
this and Moses
is burning Bush?
Oh,
I've heard ideas about that.
Yeah.
Jerusalem scholars believed now that the
burning Bush may very well have been the
occasional Bush.
Bush is a tree.
It's rich and dimethyltryptamine so that
this is.
Well,
it's sort.
He's tripping,
but I think we're getting.
We have to realize when we're
translating things from the Bible,
when you're translating from ancient
Hebrew,
which is incredibly unusual language,
where letters also double as numbers and
like the letter a is also the number one
and there's a numerical value to words
and it's a very weird language to
translate to Latin and Greek into
English,
so when we're hearing that Moses
experienced a burning Bush and that this
burning Bush was God and God gave him
these commandments on how to live your
life.
It's entirely possible that Moses was
tripping on dmt and that this burning
Bush,
that what we're getting is an
interpretation of somehow they had a dmt
experience from smoking this Bush,
right?
Smoking some aspects of it.
They figured out how to extract it or
how to,
you know,
isolated and they had a
dimethyltryptamine experience.
I love that.
Which pretty much makes sense.
That totally makes sense.
I mean we get,
we get articles submitted all the time.
It skeptic magazine of people that
attempt to make natural explanations for
biblical phenomena,
you know,
the Red Sea party because it was a giant
earthquake or you know,
the meteor strike cause the skies to
turn red and that's what,
you know,
that the plagues of frogs,
that kind of thing.
Okay.
I like,
although we published one in which the
argument was that Jesus was never,
he never died.
He was in a deep coma on the cross and
that one of his followers had stabbed,
you know,
when he got stabbed in the side with the
wound that it actually had some chemical
that put them in this coma and then they
sort of a Dan Brown thing.
They whisked him off and put them in the
cave and then,
and then,
and then stole him and he ended up in
France or India or something like that.
Okay.
Maybe you know,
I published it because I thought,
yeah,
there might be something to that.
And,
and I like those kinds of explanations.
On the other hand,
if you go into sorta your Joseph
Campbell,
Jordan Peterson role of thinking,
well,
maybe these stories or doing something
else entirely,
none of this stuff actually happened the
way it's described.
The stories are there to convey some
moral homily or some message about how
we should behave or act and that kind of
thing.
So I'm always conflicted about,
you know,
do I really want a natural explanation
for this?
Do we need to go that path?
Or maybe the stories they didn't
actually happened.
Moses has never really existed or the
people never lived in the desert for 40
years because there's no archeological
evidence that this ever happened.
Maybe it didn't happen.
Maybe it's a story that represents,
you know,
destruction,
redemption,
starting over,
something like that.
Yeah,
more likely.
Right?
Um,
are you aware at all of,
uh,
any of the translations from the Dead
Sea Scrolls?
I haven't followed that too.
There's a fascinating book to
fascinating books that were written by a
guy named
John Marco Allegro and John Mark Allegra
was a scholar who was hired to be one of
the people to decipher the Dead Sea
Scrolls and he deciphered them for over
14 years and wrote a book called the
sacred mushroom and the cross and his
interpretation was that the entire
Christian religion was a massive
misunderstanding and what it really was
that the original,
the original religion was based on was
the consumption of psychedelic mushrooms
and fertility cults and all of these
ancient parables were really just ways
that they could retain the knowledge
while hiding it from the Romans.
So they did it in the store stories and
parables,
and he even traces back the word Christ
to an ancient Sumeria word,
which means a mushroom covered in God's
semen.
Yeah.
This is what.
It's crazy.
Book has actually bought out by the
Catholic Church and then reprinted
recently by a guy named Irvin and he did
it like a five or six years ago,
maybe more.
He.
He reprints so you can buy it now,
but I have two copies of it that were
original prints that I bought from a
long time ago,
but they bought it out and send it out
to get rid of it.
Yes,
And then John Marco Allegro wrote a
second book called the Dead Sea Scrolls
and the Christian myth,
after they bought out his first book,
right?
So he has two books that are available
that are basically supporting this
theory,
but the idea was that rain would come
down and the people at the time,
we have to consider the fact that infant
mortality was incredibly high back then.
People died all the time and fertility
was very unknown.
No one really understood why people got
pregnant or how they got pregnant or
what kept people from getting pregnant.
And so people were constantly concerned
with the possibility of them going
extinct and they really were concerned
with villages getting wiped out,
their family getting wiped out.
So they were very concerned with
fertility and they thought that when it
rained,
these mushrooms that came out of the
ground,
they came out of nowhere.
Like you know how quick a mushroom
grows.
It's not like a plant.
Right?
So if there's a spore,
which by the way,
their spores everywhere,
there's my sealyham that's underneath
the earth and everywhere you go,
there's the potential for the growth of
these mushrooms.
So the rain comes down and then almost
instantaneously these mushrooms blossom
up out of the ground,
right?
You eat these mushrooms,
you have intense psychedelic
experiences.
You gather them up,
you hide it from the Romans,
you hide it from everybody.
Don't want people to know that this is
your portal to God.
And so they had all these stories that
they hit.
Now I don't know if he's right and I'm
not a religious scholar,
nor am I an expert in ancient languages,
but it's incredibly compelling.
It's really fascinating stuff.
Interesting.
Yeah.
He was a legit rock solid scholar,
right?
You know,
he was,
by the way,
he was also an ordained minister and the
only one that was on the Dead Sea
Scrolls deciphering group that was
agnostic because through his study of
religion,
once he became an ordained minister and
then became a scholar through a study of
religion,
he realized like,
oh,
these are all like ancient weird
stories,
and they're all incredibly similar and
as you go back and time you find the
similarities.
And coon Bron is where they found the
Dead Sea Scrolls is the oldest version
of the Bible.
The only one that's written in in,
I think it's the only one that's written
in Aramaic,
right?
They.
They actually had to do DNA tests
because the,
the Qumran scrolls were written on
animal skins,
so they had to do dna tests on the skins
left.
So the one they could match up the
pieces to the right animal.
Yeah.
So they had a match up the pieces of the
scroll when they were trying to piece it
all together,
like a gigantic jigsaw puzzle took them
forever to do.
Right.
I do remember a controversy from a few
years ago of the the Dead Sea Scrolls
Committee,
whoever controls them were not very
forthcoming about what they were finding
and letting go and letting outsiders
look at the originals.
Yeah,
there's some wacky stuff in there
apparently.
Yeah.
And also,
you know,
intellectual groups like that,
they tend to circle the wagons were the
elite special experts and you can't look
at these things and I think there's
that,
but I think there's also like if you're
gonna go by the way Christianity set up
those stories are,
this is what everything is based on as
many Moses,
Joseph,
all these different characters that
those stories are completely different.
Apparently in the Dead Sea Scrolls and
there's a lot of wacky stuff.
Yes.
Right.
Things coming from the sky,
like alien type stuff,
right.
Weird Shit and right.
People were probably tripping their
balls off.
You're probably.
I mean that's what I think.
It's entirely possible that the Zico
story about the thing in this guy,
and of course the ecologists think well
that they were seeing a Ufo but other.
No,
no.
They were tripping and I was much more
likely that we know for fact that
psychedelic mushrooms existed back then.
It is the easiest thing in the world to
see a mushroom pick it up and eat it.
Right.
So when people did it all the time,
they experimented with food all the
time.
There were no books to look up to see
which are the good ones to eat according
to completely make sense.
Completely makes sense.
Yeah.
And there's also in a lot of really
ancient religious art,
there's tremendous mushroom iconic
photographs of these paintings.
Uh,
there's a tremendous,
tremendous amount of mushroom imagery,
ancient Christian art.
In fact,
the actual halo,
the halo used to be different.
The Halo that we see now is like a hula
hoop around guys heads,
right?
But the old Hailu used to look like the
bottom of a mushroom cap.
Oh really?
Have you ever seen,
you know,
see if you can find those images.
I wrote an article a long time ago
called Santa Claus wasn't mushroom
because Sam,
the,
the Amany to miscarry a mushroom,
that this is all based on looks like
Santa Claus.
It's a white and red mushroom and a lot
of people and it has a microrisal
relationship with
the coniferous tree,
so that's the.
That's the mushroom.
The ammunition was scary,
but if you scroll down,
Jamie,
there's an image of see like there's all
those elves.
Look at the old.
Look at the.
Scroll up to that.
Elves up those elves.
Yeah,
that was.
It was all Christmas.
Like ancient Christmas images were
connected to that mushroom.
Now scroll down to those images of the
halo.
A look at the old halo.
The Halo looks like the bottom of a
mushroom cap.
It does kind of.
So the idea was those aren't like
markings or letters or numbers.
It's hard to tell.
Just lines.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of those though.
There's a ton of those images of ancient
religious figures with that circle
behind them with all those lines that
look exactly like the underside of a
mushroom county,
and the idea was that these enlightened
people were under the influence of
mushrooms.
That's why they had the halo on voice to
designate like,
oh,
this is the guy who was on mushrooms.
We've taught us all this stuff.
I like that.
I like that idea better than Ufo.
We know it's a real thing running and
nobody can look.
If you think you're brave,
go eat five dried grams of psilocybin
mushrooms.
Good luck.
You can't tell me they don't work.
They work on everybody.
They don't.
They don't work whether or not you
believe or not believe they just work
right?
So there's an easy way to see if you
just took them and you go,
oh,
I see why these people thought this.
Right?
Well,
my favorite biblical scholar to read is
Bart Erhman,
dino barter mill.
He Does A.
Well,
he started off as a,
as a Bible scholar because he was a
believer.
He went to the Moody Bible College.
He was going to be a preacher and
evangelical in the whole thing.
And then he went to,
I think it was Princeton theological and
he found out how the book was really
written.
It's awakened.
It was,
you know,
it's an edited volume with lots and lots
of people coming in later and modifying
this and,
and,
and debunking some previous Old
Testament in a story or whatever.
And then he ended up being an atheist or
agnostic or something,
whatever he is,
he not believe.
So this is sort of the atheist favorite
biblical scholar because he doesn't come
at it with a religious belief,
but he,
he's got a bunch of teaching company
courses where he deconstruct how Jesus,
how Jesus became the Messiah or God or
whatever.
And you know,
the Old Testament,
the new testament with these books mean
and it's a bit like a,
you know,
again,
Jordan Peterson,
you know,
I'm going to talk for two hours about
genesis one one,
how can you talk for so long?
Just a single chapter in a book,
you know,
and well there's,
there's a lot of historical
interpretation.
So I do know art historians will look at
those Halos or the thing in the sky that
the Ufo,
the UFO.
No,
no.
Actually at that time that artists were
putting those things in the sky for this
other reason.
Like,
okay,
I didn't know that,
so it's good to have some historical
background to the text or the.
Again,
I don't read Hebrew,
Greek,
Aramaic or Latin,
and so I'm trusting the King James
Bible,
which I really shouldn't,
so I rely on people like Bart who can
read it in the oldest version we have
and
know that word actually means this.
Oh,
okay.
I would be.
I mean if,
if you could get into a time machine and
go to any time in history and just see
what it was like how people behaved.
Yeah.
I'd be real tempted to go to ancient
Egypt,
but I'd also really be tempted to go to
around the time of Christ.
I mean,
I don't necessarily even know if Christ
was a real human,
but I would love to see what life was
like back then.
Bart Bart thinks he probably did exist
and obviously not the Messiah,
not the supernatural step,
but that somebody like that or by that
name.
Yeshua was not that unusual name.
Probably did a lot of the stuff he did.
This is itinerant preacher and so on,
so I'm on board with that.
I'm not part of the group.
The atheists say he never even existed,
completely made up story.
I don't think so.
Uh,
and I actually,
in the heavens and earth I conclude
probably erroneously are in the minority
position that when he said the kingdom
is within or in more famous passage that
I'm there,
my disciples standing here now will not
die before they see the son of man
return and these kinds of things in the
gospels.
I think his message was,
there is no place that you're going to,
when you,
after you died that heaven is here,
this is it.
We have to make the most of it.
And it's,
it's a message that you would give to
people that are suppressed,
oppressed by the Romans.
So I call this the oppression redemption
myth.
You know,
that,
that it's a story of a,
of like the native American ghost dance
in 1890.
You know,
when they're like an oppressed people,
they're about to be wiped out in a
messiah.
Comes and says,
you know,
it's all going to be great.
You know,
we're going to change everything.
The buffalo are coming back.
If you wear this sweater,
it'll be impervious to white man's
bullets and it was a very Christ like a
story.
Uh,
and,
and when you start looking at it,
you see,
oh,
this,
this story that comes up a lot in
history among oppressed peoples as a way
of saying we got to circle the wagons
and take care of our own against these
oppressors and make a better life here.
Yeah.
It just makes sense that there'd be so
many parallels and you think about
history and how many people were in pr,
oppressed and how often these narratives
repeated themselves over and over again
when people got into power and then
invaded others.
And yeah,
it's brutal history.
I was just,
I'm just reading a Neil Ferguson's new
book,
the tower and the square.
It's about that,
the tension throughout all of human
history,
civilization between hierarchical,
top down power structures and horizontal
network power structures and that
they're always intention,
but mostly throughout history.
It's the top down power,
whoever's.
And so his is one chapter opens with
that scene from the good,
the bad and the ugly.
When,
um,
when Eli Wallach and cleanness twitter
facing off each other in the cemetery
and uh,
and cleanness which shoots the other guy
that really the bad guy.
And then Eli Wallach tries to shoot his
gun and it's empty and so cleanness
would walk over to him and he says,
there are two kinds of men in this
world.
Those who have loaded revolvers.
And those who dig your going to dig.
Ferguson uses this star to say basically
that's the history of civilization.
Somebody who's got the loaded gun and
everyone else is going to dig.
It's amazing that we made it this far.
I mean we live in such.
I mean I know that there's troubles
today and I know we have issues in our,
in our own society and forget about
other parts of the world,
which there's horrific things happening
right now,
but in comparison to just a few thousand
years ago,
you would not want to live back there.
It'd be fun to go to visit.
If you come back.
I would want to go into a giant
bulletproof hamster bubble,
like one of those roller and just like
maybe where they couldn't see you.
I just want to be there.
They can't see me.
Just.
I would love to observe and see what.
Because we have all these like I'm
watching this show Vikings,
right?
And Oh man,
it pissed me off.
Episode two,
this guy puts his feet up on the table
and he's got rubber bottom soles of his
shoe.
My Cue motherfuckers.
He has a heel that's clearly made in a
factory and there's like this textured
plastic bottom to his shoe.
I'm like,
how did no one catch this?
You guys have this amazing wardrobe and
all these ships and I'll take a picture
of it now.
I'll put it up on my instagram later was
so dumb.
It made me angry,
but I'm watching this and I'm like,
how do we know this was how they talked?
How do we know this is what they did?
How do we.
This is some weird interpretation of
some historical events really are to
interpret and of course thoughts don't
fossilize.
So I started early in the book about,
you know,
who were the first people to figure out
we're going to die and become aware of
our own mortality in a way that,
well,
maybe I can conceive of being somewhere
else.
I don't actually die.
So we,
we know,
uh,
you know,
an elephant's grieve and mammals grieve
and Cetaceans,
dolphins,
whales,
and so on.
And chimps,
they,
you know,
they feel these mothers are just
depressed and suicidal when they're
infants die.
But that's different from conceiving of
like,
well,
I know I'm going to die because I see
people around me that I could conceive
of maybe some other place to go.
So I start off with something of a
paradox that if I asked you to imagine
yourself dead,
you can't do it because to imagine
anything,
you have to be alive.
So it's not going to be like falling
asleep and waking up the next morning
because you have dreams or whatever.
It's going to be more like general
anesthesia where it's,
you know,
10,
nine,
eight,
boom,
boom lights out and you.
But you just never wake up.
So.
And we,
we talk about things like,
well there's nothing after death but,
but even the word no thing implies
there's a thing or you know,
you're going to this place,
this another,
there's nothing,
no thing or nowhere.
It implies that there is aware that
you're not going to,
but there's not even aware that you're
not going to.
And it's like,
you know,
with Lawrence Krauss and some of these
cosmologists,
you know,
what was there before the big bang.
So when you say,
well imagine the universe,
stars,
planets or galaxies,
no light,
but there's not even any space or time.
And at some point you just don't have
the words,
Stephen's say what it is we're trying to
talk about.
There's,
there's nothing before the big bang.
You can't even ask actually talk about
it.
Well don't they think now though,
that it's in,
it's entirely possible that the big bang
is like a cycle.
Yeah.
Well I think it's something like that I
think spans and contracts infinitely
forever that that's a preferable.
Well again,
we have to come up with some way to talk
about it.
So we also have this weird biological
idea based on our own limitations that
there's a birth and a death of
everything,
right?
So actually have a chapter devoted to
Deepak Chopra and the eastern wisdom
traditions were kind of buddies now.
And yeah,
I went to his center down in Carlsbad
and spend some time there and I think
he's all right.
He's a good guy.
Yeah.
Now he's totally a good guy.
I mean,
he,
he's been.
And at times in the past,
either misleading or misled.
Yes.
Sometimes that's right.
Um,
you know,
some of his recommendations for dietary
things or whatever perhaps.
But I know for sure because I've gotten
to know him pretty well,
that he totally believes this stuff.
He says,
uh,
it sounds like woo as I used to call it
a,
but a lot of it,
if you interpret it from a kind of a
Buddhist,
western,
Buddhist position know when he says,
uh,
you know,
consciousness is the ground of all
being.
It's the ontological primitive.
These things that sound nonsensical.
But if you think about it sort of a,
from a simple perspective,
the entire universe is in your brain and
when you cease to exist,
the university says to exist for you,
but you're in your brain.
I call it the week consciousness
principle.
It's sort of true by definition.
Now he goes a little bit further and
says,
you know,
that consciousness is everything and
that we bring into existence material
stuff by thinking about her observing it
or whatever.
And here's some quantum physics
experiments that are really spooky.
And it's like,
okay,
time out.
You know,
quantum physics is weird and spooky.
Consciousness is weird and spooky.
That doesn't mean they're connected.
He thinks they are.
So it's a debatable point.
Okay.
Uh,
but still,
um,
the,
the experience of going in and so I did
the meditation thing and all the
massages and the teas and the food and
all that stuff.
And it's,
it's this beach side resort in Carl's
bed.
You can't help but feeling better.
Like,
yeah,
this stuff works.
Whereas Carlsbad,
it's down by Encinitas.
North of San Diego has a beautiful area.
Totally beautiful.
Yeah.
He's Kinda deep box.
Not done yet,
he's got a good thing going and not just
the bucket,
you know,
there's other people like Sam Harris at
Bob Wright has a new book out called why
Buddhism is true and okay,
so it works.
So we're back to does it work?
What do you mean by does it work?
Not just for me,
I had an experience and I felt better.
We've got to do better than that for
science.
So what Deepak and a brighter talking
about is that is that the Western
version of Buddhism may actually work
medically.
It may lower stress hormones in your
body,
but a lower
blood pressure.
These kinds of things that are
measurable because that's what we want
to know from a western scientific
perspective.
Not just do I feel better,
but 67 percent of the people who did
this particular treatment,
they got better by these measurable
criteria.
Okay.
That's.
That seems fair enough to me.
I'm open to that now.
This idea that there's nothing or no
thing that we can't even.
We can't even wrap our head around
nothing because we would think of a
thing that there's no thing,
but there's never a thing.
Right,
right.
But how do we or why?
Why don't we just say we don't know.
Why don't we speculate on the
possibility of consciousness being some
sort of ethereal thing or something that
exists outside of the Bible?
We don't know.
We really don't.
That's what I say.
I,
I conclude and you know,
I don't know if there's an afterlife or
not at very end of the book.
We can come back to this later.
I just say it doesn't really matter
whether there's an afterlife or not
because we don't live in the afterlife.
We live in this one,
so this is the time you got to do
whatever you gotta do.
I call this elvis error a lob is lv
singer.
Woody Allen's character in Annie Hall.
I remember the scene early in the movie
where he has a flashback as a young boy
and his.
He's in the psychiatrist office with his
mom and you know,
what's the problem?
He won't do his homework.
You don't do your homework.
Why don't you do your homework,
Alvin?
He says the universe is expanding and he
says the universe is expanding,
goes to the universe,
is everything there is,
and if it's expanding one day it's all
gonna blow apart,
so nothing really matters.
I'm not going to do my homework,
and his father yells at him,
what is the universe?
Got To do this.
We live in Brooklyn.
Brooklyn is not expanding,
so that's my sort of take home message.
We don't live in the afterlife or before
the universe or after the.
None of that matters.
I mean it's interesting to talk about,
but we live in this life so this is what
really counts.
They're fascinating things to
contemplate,
but ultimately you really,
for practicality sake,
you really should be paying attention to
life.
Totally.
I mean,
this is what I tell deep buck all the
time when he says he bought,
you know Michael,
this table is actually made of atoms
that are mostly empty space and the
quantum physicists,
but according to Sean Carroll,
that's not correct over there,
right?
Yeah.
He explained that this idea of empty
space.
He's like,
no,
that's just a poor way of describing it.
I would defer to him and let him
describe it.
He also described the superpositions
particles,
subatomic particles being in super
position where they're in a state of
moving and not moving at the same time.
He explained that in a way that
completely fucked my head up too.
I'm like,
well,
I thought I had figured out sort of.
I thought,
I know.
I didn't think I had to figure it out,
but I thought I had a definition that at
least was like,
okay,
well it's this even though I don't
understand,
and he's like,
no,
it's not even that.
Okay.
So yeah,
so I refer to be pleased if you're
interested,
go to this Sean Carroll podcast,
as I understand it anyway,
that it doesn't really matter because
the atoms are jiggling in a way that
this is solid.
You could tell it solid and this is the
level
we live at.
So many drops on your head.
You're,
you're in trouble.
That's right.
Yeah.
So again,
we don't live in a quantum world.
We live in a macro world where this kind
of stuff does matter.
Okay.
So,
um,
you know,
to,
for Deepak the whole Western way of
thinking scientifically,
there's a beginning and an end time is a
linear thing that we could measure and
there's birth and death,
all that is the wrong way to think about
it.
That the Buddhist way is that it's just
all consciousness.
And when you die,
you returned to the conscious state you
were before you were in before you were
born.
So,
so the physical body is just an
instantiation of this conscious thing,
whatever this is.
And,
and,
okay,
I,
you know,
I don't know,
uh,
you know,
I'd be surprised,
but I'll be pleasantly surprised.
I'll tell you that if it turns out,
know close my eyes for the last time and
I wake up and,
you know,
there's deep pockets,
whoever my friends,
Carl Sagan and Stephen Jay Gould and all
the greats,
Asimov are there.
Everybody's there.
Hitches there,
you know,
it's like,
oh boy,
okay,
this isn't,
this isn't hell.
Uh,
if that's true,
you know,
I'm not against any of this.
Just like I'm not against Ray Kurzweil
in these guys figuring out that we can
live 200 years or 300 years.
Great.
If you can do it,
you know,
but let's just,
so when they say to me,
Sherman,
don't you want to live to be $500,
it's like just get me to 80 without
prostate cancer.
Give me the 90 without Alzheimer's,
you know,
100 to 100.
So I'm not on a morphine drip in a bed,
you know,
just quality of life incrementally year
by year.
And if it turns out you solve these
problems and we lived $150,
$200,
then we have a bunch of other problems
we don't even know about yet.
Okay.
Well I think there's some beauty in
temporary things that we,
for whatever reason we're,
we're avoiding that concept.
We were terrified of things ending and
there's beauty and things being
temporary,
right?
You don't want to go to see a movie
that's 100 hours long.
That's a movie's a great movement is 90
minutes you're in your app,
maybe two hours.
If it's three hours,
if it's blade runner or something,
something crazy like Christopher
hitchens in my book is I love his
analogy.
First of all,
you're at the party and death taps you
on the shoulder says you have to leave
and worse the party is going to go on
without you and they're going to all
have fun.
It's like,
oh no,
but if the Christian version of of,
of Heaven and Hell is real,
you're tap on their shoulder at the
party until you can never leave the
party.
It's like,
oh,
that's even worse.
I don't want to.
I don't want to do anything forever.
Right,
and imagine the classical version of
what heaven is like a guy with a harp
and there's a bunch of babies with
wings,
like what are even that aside,
this way?
Hitch called it a celestial North Korea.
You have a dictator that knows all of
your thoughts and everything you're
going to do.
It's like,
wait a minute that that does not sound
like fun to me.
That seems to me to be the inevitable
future though.
That's one of the things that I'm really
nervous about the dystopian version of
technological interference in our lives.
I'm an entirely convinced that we're
going to,
in inside of 100 years,
live in a world where all of your
thoughts really are documented and
there's
there's they have access to them the
same way.
No one in their wildest dreams conceived
to photographs for hundred years ago.
In 400 years from now,
we're going to have the ability to
record record thoughts and ideas and
they're going to be able to read the
contents of each other's minds.
That could be well maybe that maybe we
need some regulation there for that
maybe or maybe we just have to accept
the fact that most of what goes wrong in
the world goes wrong because people can
think the secret,
sneaky,
fucked up thoughts and when those no
longer exist anymore,
maybe it will clean out human behavior.
There was an at our limits episode about
that in the 19 fifties.
It might've been the other one pilot
tell twilight zone where this guy all of
a sudden is able to read the minds of
other people and he's at work and he's
listening to all these conversations and
you know,
all this fun stuff.
But then this one guy who's really dark,
like he's gonna,
he's gonna come in and blow everybody
away and sort of climax is where he,
you know,
he comes in and tells the boss and
everybody in it and they,
you know,
they go in there and it turns out the
guy says,
well,
I was never going to do that.
I was just angry and I was just thinking
that,
you know,
so that's like a minority report thing,
you could have these thoughts.
We know from research that this is David
buses research on.
He wrote a book on murders,
the murder next door it's called.
And so he did the research on asking
subjects.
Have you ever thought about killing
somebody you didn't like?
It turns out like 80 percent of guys and
67 percent of women have had homicidal
fantasies in their life.
Now 90 nine point nine percent of us
never act on her homicidal fantasies,
but we get mad at us if we can imagine
and he's got the narrative accounts
because he also asked him,
tell me what you would do and Oh my God,
they're just incredible to read.
Like I would break every bone in his
body and then I would pull out his
fingernails and then I would just say
they go onto your.
You're like,
Holy Shit,
but it's just fantasy.
Fantasy.
Yeah.
Some people have suicidal fantasies.
It's people that have fantasies of
jumping off of a giant building.
Right.
You what I mean,
but most don't act on it.
Most don't act on it and there's people
that just have these thoughts and they
think I'm.
They look at the edge and they go,
I could just jump off right now and and
this whole thing,
but I won't and shouldn't be punished
them.
No,
of course not.
The minority report scenario,
it's like,
okay,
we found out that this guy's thinking
about robbing the bank,
so he had a fantasy about it.
He's going to do it.
I've thought about doing that.
You have,
not really,
but just really fleet and I was like,
what would I do if I had to rob this
bank?
I mean,
I've never actually considered robbing a
bank,
but I thought,
okay,
I'm at the bank.
What am I just decided to pull out a gun
and everybody gets the floor.
Where's the,
where's the cameras?
Where's the security guard?
You know,
like you've seen so many movies.
It's a if you're bored,
you know,
but today that's another thing.
People are rarely board because when
they are,
they just pull out their phones,
stare at pictures of their butts.
It's like,
you know,
you just pull out facebook or instagram.
No longer board.
When I was in my religious phase and in,
uh,
in college I asked,
that was before I went to pepperdine,
which is a religious clothes at Glendale
College,
just to get my g out of the way.
And my philosophy professor was an
atheist and I was an evangelical.
So I'm telling them about Jesus and the
whole thing and the after life.
And he said he want to know are there
golf courses and tennis courts in
heaven?
Because I gotta have something to do,
I'd be bored.
I thought I have no idea and need.
Yeah,
I know,
but it'd be with cheese.
I want to play golf.
Then I also quote from Julia Sweeney is
letting go of God monologue that she
opens this monologue,
you know,
dealing with the Mormon boys coming by
or her house in,
in Hollywood,
and they're pitching their story like,
okay,
come on in and pitch me your story.
Like it's a Hollywood movie script.
You know,
what do you got?
So they tell her the whole time it's
going to be great.
You know,
the blind shall see again that Jeff
Shell here again,
and your body will be whole again.
And so she says,
well,
let's see.
Um,
I had uterine cancer.
So I had my uterus taken out.
Do I get my uterus back when I go to
heaven?
They said,
yeah.
She goes,
I don't want it back.
What if you had a nose job and you liked
it?
They'll have to get my old nose back.
It's true.
I'd say openness.
A little funny story because it gets to
the problem of identity.
Who are you?
So if you're resurrected with Jesus,
he early earlier Christian sex before
descartes introduced dualism.
They believe that you are,
when you're resurrected at the,
you know,
after your death,
you are physically there in heaven
physically and your soul.
The whole thing.
It's just one thing.
So the question is,
well,
how old are you when you're there?
You know,
so you're brought up and there you are
sitting next to Jesus and God and
whatever,
you know.
So they.
Okay,
30,
30 seems like a good year.
It's a year.
Jesus was crucified.
Okay.
Thirty.
Like,
but wait a minute and I'm 63 now.
So what happens is all the memories of
my life for the last 33 years.
Oh No,
you get all those memories.
Okay?
But the memory,
the memory of my being 30 now is
different from the memory I had when I
was 50 of being 30 and 40 being 30.
And even when I was in my thirties being
30,
you know,
the,
the memories are always changing and
edited in,
in,
um,
and forgotten or modified if it,
particularly based on life experiences
that happened afterwards.
So in your twenties,
you go to this college,
he marry this person and you take this
job or whatever,
you don't really know what the Info,
the impact of those decisions are until
much later in life,
which is why we think it's ridiculous
for people to write memoirs in their
twenties or thirties because they're
celebrities.
You have no idea what those things
actually mean until much later.
So this is the problem of who you are.
So first of all,
we,
we already know that none of your body
is the same material.
It was,
say a decade ago.
Your cells are all recycled.
The molecules and atoms are gone.
There's new ones that replace it.
It's the pattern.
It's the pattern of information that
represents you,
Joe Rogan.
This is what you look like.
These are your memories.
So somehow that this has to be copied.
So in the Ray Kurzweil scenario of the
singularity,
we're going to upload the mind.
They're going to copy your connectome,
all your memories in your synapses.
Okay?
So right away there's the problem of,
well,
which memories will all of them?
No,
there are no fixed set of memories that
are you.
Your memories are always changing.
So the moment you take a snapshot of it,
that's just a fixed point.
That's not you really.
You are this whole long continuum.
Uh,
that's always kind of flexible and
changing.
So there's that.
And then there's the problem with the
mind uploading scenario is there's two
kinds of cells.
There's the memory cells meme self of
all your memories,
and then there's the point of view,
self pov self.
So when you go to sleep tonight,
you wake up tomorrow,
you're still looking at the world
through your eyes,
and there's a continuity of point of
view from one day to the next.
Same thing with general anesthesia.
So like in the Johnny Depp movie,
Transcendence,
where he is poisoned by these terrorists
and he's dying,
he's got to,
like a week ago,
he copies his mind connect.
Um,
quilvent of the genome and puts it into
a computer and then he dies and they
turned the computer on and he's in the
computer looking out through the little
camera hole.
I don't see how this could happen.
That is if we copied you,
your connectome,
everything,
all your memories.
So we had a Joe Rogan number two copy
ready to go,
but instead of you dying,
let's say we had a sophisticated.
If Mri brain scan machine slid you into
it,
copied your connectome,
uploaded it into the cloud or whatever,
and then we slide you back out and
you're standing there,
you,
you're still looking at the world
through your eyes.
That's just Joe Rogan.
Number two,
a copy and no more.
Do you look at that than a twin looks at
it.
Sibling and says,
well,
there I am.
No,
no,
you're still standing.
They go,
no,
I'm here.
That's just a copy of me.
And so this to me seems a a central
problem with the mindup loading
scenario.
It's just a copy.
Did you see the thing in national
geographic today about the clone
monkeys?
No,
they've,
they've managed to actually clone
monkeys.
No.
Yeah,
so Jamie,
I uh,
I tweeted it earlier today.
It's crazy and were speculating that if
they can do that two monkeys,
they're going to be able to be able to
do that to humans.
But again,
so who is right?
Who is that?
If there's a Michael Shermer.
Is it your twin?
I mean like when you meet twins,
they,
it's very weird.
Like I used to date a girl who was a
twin.
She had a sister looked exactly like
her,
but like a little,
just a something just to feel like
you're not super,
super confusing.
So they weren't the same person but they
pretty much were.
Yeah.
Here's the,
here's the article,
scroll up there,
clone monkeys created in the lab.
Now what?
Yeah.
Okay,
well,
so you're making copies so it's a copy,
but it's not the same person because
they had their own individual life
experiences.
The moment you and your copy start
diverging away and lead leading
different lives,
you're gonna have different memories you
should have on your show.
Nancy Siegel from cal state fullerton.
She's the world's leading twin expert.
And she has all these great scenarios.
She a new book out called accidental
brothers and she has another book out on
switched at birth and Nancy Siegel and,
and,
and these are scenarios that not only do
we have the behavior genetics studies
because she worked on the famous
Minnesota twins research,
not the baseball team at the twins
research of twins separated at birth and
raised in different environments.
Like,
you know,
the one raised in a Jewish home,
the other raised the Nazi Germany.
They get together,
they have the same watch,
they wear the same kind of clothes,
they use the same toothpaste.
They married women that look pretty,
pretty similar,
you know.
So there's a lot that genetics does
that.
It's very subtle.
There's no gene for like,
we're both Catholic or wearing this kind
of close.
But you know,
if you have.
Nancy explains that if you have a
certain body type,
which twins are going to have almost the
exact same body type.
Certain clothes are going to look better
on you and you're more likely to pick
those.
So by chance are more likely to get
similarly.
There's no genes for clothes,
but something like that body type or
temperament,
you know,
you have a certain kind of temperament,
at least half of which is,
is heritable.
So you're more likely to choose certain
professions or prefer certain hobbies or
activities or pick spouses that are kind
of,
you know,
that would gel well with that
temperament.
So this,
if you make good decisions though,
well yeah,
there is that.
There's an element of volition.
The choices you make in life do diverge
a little bit.
So they're twins are a little bit
different from that,
but yeah.
Um,
but so a clone,
you know,
again,
the moment you start leading separate
lives,
so why the copy of you is not going to
be you in heaven in religions have the
same problem and you know,
if God is able to reconstruct your body
like,
like a transporter.
I got into the world of Star Trek when I
was writing this book.
It's like,
oh my God,
they have this whole webpages devoted to
what does the transport do?
It's like,
okay,
first of all,
you know,
there's no transport it,
right?
This is just science fiction,
it could be whatever it wants,
but is it copy and paste,
they just copy you and reconstruct you
on.
So with Adams on the other side or is it
cut and paste or is it the.
They actually moved the atoms and
reconstruct it anyway,
but it does get to the problem of
identity.
Well,
what are you really because you don't
have to.
It's not the matter the material.
It's really the pattern which is why the
singularity people focus on the cloud
and uploading the mind because the
information but the information is
always changing and how does the point
of view go with it?
See what the cryonics.
I can at least imagine that if I'm
frozen and woken up somehow a thousand
years from now that I'd wake up like
like do after surgery or sleep.
I can't see how that would happen.
If you flip on the switch and the
computer or in the cloud or whatever,
that I'd be there going,
Oh,
here I am.
Well,
isn't there also the problem that every.
What is it,
seven to 10 years?
Every cell in your body essentially
replaced except your neurons.
There's that.
That's right.
Yeah.
So are we just are neurons would.
That's the idea that that's what the
singularity or not your nose job.
That's fake,
but fake lips.
That's your neurons only.
But even there,
see the transhumanists they imagined
this transitional stage where you start
wearing contact lenses.
Say they can call up the Internet.
And the moment I see you Joe Rogan,
the name pops up,
your wikipedia page pops up.
And I know now I have this information
so I'm not bionic.
But uh,
but I'm also not just human transhuman.
Okay.
So then,
then who are you?
Right?
So these are the sort of the
transitional stage.
So a cochlear implant.
Is it kind of a brain chip and you know,
probably,
I think you know about that research of
the paraplegic quadriplegic man who can
control his computer a cursor and now
they can actually control a fake
artificial limb just by thinking about
it.
So they put a chip in his motor cortex
that reads the thoughts.
So he has these thoughts and he's been
trained to pull the cup of water up to
his mouth and drink with the artificial
arm at some point,
you know,
say 50 years,
a hundred years from now,
we should,
we could have it all mapped and you can
control your whole environment just by
thinking,
you know,
I would like to hear Mozart and you just
think about it and then the music in
your house comes on and it's Mozart.
Well,
I,
I freak out about Siri sometimes,
like,
um,
my daughter asked me about a song that
she likes and we were in the car and I
pressed the Siri Button on my phone and
I said,
hey,
it's some,
what's that new musical with the,
what's his name?
Hugh Jackman Wolverine Guy.
Some some musical that's based on
ringling brothers and Barnum and Bailey
circus.
She wanted the song.
I,
I literally asked Siri to do it.
And it started playing it instantly,
like within a couple of seconds.
Like this is crazy that this thing just
pulled it out of the sky and it's
playing it in my car.
Yep.
I did that the other night.
I wanted to hear Bob segers Hollywood
nights.
I'm not sure why I got that in my head
and it popped right up.
There's a youtube video of him from
1978.
Just rocking it.
It's like,
wow.
It's amazing that I'm just driving on
the freeway.
Heading back home to Santa Barbara.
I'd like to hear Bob Seger.
Hollywood nights.
Wow.
There it is.
The greatest showman.
That's okay.
My daughter loves that movie,
so she wanted to hear the song,
but I just talked to the phone and it
did that.
When are we going to get past that?
Talking to the phone instead of
thinking.
Yeah,
because I'm pretty comfortable with
looking for it.
Let me.
Hold on,
honey,
let me find it online.
I'm going to go get it.
Okay.
Let me download it.
Let me pay for it.
Let me use my thumbprint or whatever,
and then now it's just talk to your
phone right when.
When is it?
Just pull it up.
I want to hear led Zeppelin.
Whole Lotta love.
I'll just.
I'll just start thinking that starts
playing and when is that going to
happen?
That's probably coming.
We're,
we're probably all going to give in to
some sort of a chip.
Something that we can get implanted.
Simple,
easy trans dermal device,
you know,
fashionable.
You'd go to a club,
it glows who you got the new one,
iphone 38.
Yeah.
I think all that's far more likely to
happen before we get to the point where
you could copy and entire brain in and
put
it in a clone of your body.
I interviewed Kurzweil and uh,
I had a really interesting conversation
with him for the Scifi show that was
doing a few years back and uh,
I find him to be very interesting.
He's a fascinating,
incredibly intelligent guy that has,
I think he has more than a hundred
different patents and things things
invented.
He's a genius.
He's a bonafide genius,
but I also found it incredibly,
a sad his motivation,
like what he's trying to do,
you know,
he's trying to recreate his father.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
Because they didn't see that,
uh,
the documentary better.
Yes.
Yeah.
Transcended,
it was kind of sad.
It's dark,
it's very dark and he's got all his
basement is filled with all his dad's
stuff and um,
you know,
he always talking about life,
life,
but he just really kind of obsessed with
death.
This is what I worry about is that
again,
back to the Elvis era,
you know,
we don't live in,
in the next life,
whatever that is or the far future we
live now and don't miss it if you're so
focused on death and,
and how we can solve these problems.
Okay.
I'm glad somebody working on it and he's
head of engineering for all of Google
now and they had that company,
Calico,
so a couple of hundred million dollars
working on aging problems.
Great.
Again,
if you could solve Alzheimer's,
those things,
that's great,
but you know,
don't be so focused on the next life you
miss out.
Well,
I don't necessarily know if he is so
focused that he's missing out.
I don't think he's missing out on.
I think he has extraordinary vision in
terms of like what is possible with the
exponential increase of technology.
So I think having a guy like that
around,
it's helpful.
It's.
I think it's beneficial to everybody.
It's incredibly fascinating to hear him
talk about those things.
You know?
I'm too dumb to know if he's right.
What I'm hearing him talk,
I'm like,
you think really?
Thank you.
Yes.
By 20,
45 will be downloading our brain into a
computer.
Mind man,
I don't know.
That shit seems close.
Yeah,
it's 2018 man.
I mean when I interviewed him,
I think it was probably 2013 or
somewhere around then.
Although to be fair,
if you said,
you know,
a century ago when they had telegraphed,
well more than a century ago,
the invention of the Telegraph,
but you know,
in a century and a half or so you're
going to be pressing a button and just
calling out what you want on a little
box.
It'd be like urine saying this,
what are you talking about?
Smoking?
And here we are,
you know,
so this way science fiction is usually
set far enough in advance like a century
or two rather than in the historical
present.
So that you can populate these kinds of
things.
This is what science fiction writers
tell me.
If you set it up far enough,
uh,
readers are willing to suspend disbelief
because.
Yeah,
it seems possible.
Look what we've been able to do.
So.
Okay,
fair enough.
If we can do that,
um,
I'm all for it.
That'd be great.
Yeah.
I'm all for it too.
But boy,
I don't know.
I'm,
I've been very convinced and more so
over time that human beings in this form
that our time is limited.
I think.
Yes,
when artificial.
And I think even the word artificial
life is a weird word to throw around
because it's not going to be artificial.
It's going to be an actual thing,
right?
It's just going to be non biological.
Right.
And I think it's,
I think that's what life is outside of
earth.
I think that humans,
what we do with our curiosity,
if there's other curiosity in,
in the universe,
other curious life forms,
I think they probably do the same thing.
They realized,
well,
there's a massive limitation in terms of
biological tissue and in terms of our
ability to evolve like,
well,
I could just reprogram a phone.
Your phone involves way quicker than
people.
They go back to the goodyear.
I have an iphone x right now.
Go back and think about an iphone one.
That's a piece of shit that you have to
go back to a decade,
a decade.
Then it go back to that clinic.
Seti scientists or scientists tend to be
skeptical of the UFO alien abduction
stories because if we do encounter
aliens coming here,
they're not going to be biological.
Yeah,
they're going to be computers or
machines because that's the only thing
they can survive the long distances.
Long time of interstellar space flight.
Yeah.
I think we're just so wrapped up in the
idea of biology being so important that
you have to.
It has to breed the normal way with eggs
and sperm or otherwise.
It's bullshit.
I mean we think of it,
you know,
but biology is,
wet stuff,
but really their machines,
a cell is a machine.
It's just processing molecules,
which is what nanobots are going to do.
They're going to process molecule.
So it's really just.
They're all machines.
Yeah.
There's cellular machines and,
and you know when they talk about things
like quantum computing and things get
really squirrely,
like,
Whoa,
wait a minute,
what are you saying?
Well,
what do you mean by quantum computing?
Right?
Like where is this?
Is this a computer?
Like does this use like a regular
motherboard?
Like how does it have a CPU?
Like uh,
what,
what's,
what's next stage after that?
Like what do you know?
What,
what resemblance is it going to have to.
Anything that we think of today in terms
of technology that we're accustomed to.
Right.
You know,
so it really makes the point that,
you know,
if he try track,
say back to the 19 fifties where you
have computers the size of this room
down to now.
Okay.
So you just keep the curve going and
eventually there'll be the size of blood
cells and you just ingest these little
computers and then go in there and they
fix your mutant dna in the bacteria that
are in there.
They repair blood vessels,
that sort of thing.
This is what he's envisioning and I can
conceive of it in principle,
I think,
but they're,
I forget whose law is in any,
any trend that cannot go on forever,
won't.
So.
Right.
So if it gets to a certain,
like the,
like Moore's law,
the doubling of that can't go on
forever.
Now the quantum computing people say,
Oh yes,
that's right.
It'll stop,
but we're going to do this other thing
that is completely okay.
Okay,
fine.
Well boy,
I just,
I mean there's so many things to
speculate about in terms of our
potential future,
you know,
and the,
the,
the fear of death is a very odd one.
It's normal,
it's natural,
it's biological.
Animals have it.
Every human has it.
Everyone's scared to die.
No one's scared to go to sleep,
but everyone's scared to die.
And it's this idea that this would be
the end of the party,
right?
But really there's nothing to fear
because you won't even know it.
Right?
He is.
As long as you're alive,
you're Santi and conscious of existence.
And then not.
So.
I mean,
when you ask people to quote surveys in
the book,
you know,
how long would you like to live it?
It's always about what the average
lifespan is.
Now.
People go,
Oh yeah,
I think I'd like to live in [inaudible]
82 or so.
But if we fast forward you to 80.
Okay,
your time's up.
Tomorrow's your day.
No way to get.
Give me another week.
Okay,
here's everybody I need another month.
A year to run my first marathon.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
I contend that it's a silly argument
that you know,
that people say,
well,
I think we should have a limit on our,
our lifespan and that we need to die,
you know,
but,
but you personally,
are you going to check out when it's
your time?
No,
of course they would.
As long as we're talking about being
healthy and in,
in,
in cognitively aware,
then most people want to continue.
Let me severely depressed suicide.
Yes,
that's an issue,
but most people would want to continue
on.
So that's a point in favor of the
transhumanists that yeah,
people will want to keep going on as
long as they're healthy and happy and
leading fulfilled lives.
Yeah.
As long as everything's healthy.
My grandmother had a stroke and they
gave her 72 hours.
She wound up living 12 years.
Oh Wow.
And it was,
it was awful.
She had,
she had an aneurysm.
Oh,
the 12 years was awful.
It was awful.
It was horrific.
Yeah,
it was really bad.
She was bedridden.
She would moan.
She was always in pain.
When she died,
it was a relief for everyone in the
family.
It wasn't like,
oh,
we lost.
Grandma was like grandma's mps now
because for the longest time she was in
agony.
It was.
I stayed with them when I first moved to
New York.
They lived in New Jersey and I live with
them for a few months while I was saving
up money for an apartment and um,
it was a horrific man.
She would be moaning and grandfather had
to take care of her and they had a nurse
would come over and take care of her as
well.
It was just a,
I think Europeans have a more advanced
humanist type perspective on that
euthanasia or physician assisted
suicide.
Well,
they're doing that now and a few states,
but there's still this kind of sort of
Christian ethic of only God can decide
that you can't make those decisions.
And these are people more like Christian
conservatives who otherwise think the
government should stay out of your life
and you make your own and you
take personal responsibility except when
it comes to your death.
Like,
well,
wait a minute,
why can't I choose that?
While they worry about abuse?
Okay,
fine.
Just have rules about,
you know,
you have to sign something and we have
to.
Video Kevorkian used to video tape,
you know,
his patients saying,
I,
I choose to do this when they could
still do it anyway.
So yeah,
I mean,
um,
how we deal with death.
It's always been a huge problem.
It makes people uncomfortable.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
how we talk about it matters and I mean,
one of the motives for me writing this
book is like I've written about science
and pseudoscience.
Science and religion.
Science and guts signed some morality,
but,
you know,
really this is the big question.
You know,
what happens when you die and this
something that you know,
that people think about a lot or they
thought about a lot for a long time and
uh,
you know,
so,
and nobody knows.
I contend,
you know,
nobody knows for sure.
And uh,
so we write these stories that kind of
make us feel better because the whole
theory called terror management theory
that is premised on the idea that fear
of death is what drives civilization and
creativity and productivity and
architects and artists and scientists
are driven by this fear of death.
But if you ask people,
do you walk around in a state of fear of
death?
Most?
No,
I don't to it.
Okay.
It's unconscious.
Maybe.
But how do you know if it's unconscious?
So we have to hit these experiments with
a prime.
The brain sort of try to trick it out of
you and almost aren't they?
Most people are busy.
They're busy.
Yeah.
The fear of death comes when you're
living alone at night.
Right?
What is it going to be a day when I
don't wake up?
Right.
It's gonna.
Maybe he'll die tonight while I'm
sleeping,
but you'd never know.
You just,
you just,
it's just lights out and that's,
that's the greatest way to die.
Ever go to sleep and don't wake up.
That's right.
Yup.
Guy In your bed peacefully.
That's a good way to go.
Which is why,
you know,
hospice is probably,
a really good thing that we're getting
better at it in the west of just helping
people make that transition,
which is why back to near death
experiences.
It could be those brain chemistry,
the brain chemicals.
That's what they evolved for was to help
that process.
As your brain is shutting down,
you feel this sort of glow or this sort
of good feeling that you know there's a
tunnel you're going to pass through the
sense of transitioning to some other
place,
and this starts off very early in life
I.
I cite research by Paul Bloom and his
lab at Yale with little kids,
so he presents them with this little
puppet show and so you have this little
mouse and this alligator and the
alligator munches the mouse and he's
dead.
Where's the mouse now?
Oh,
the mouse at this.
Other than this other place and he
misses his mom and he's hungry and he's
scared.
So and this is like preschoolers.
So it starts pretty young that this
dualistic idea that something transcends
the physical body.
There's something else that continues
and I contend that that's because you
can't conceive of nothing that just
don't perceive my own brain operating.
So it feels like thoughts are floating
around up there and I feel like a kind
of a set of patterns that would continue
beyond the physical body feels that way.
So our intuitions I think naturally lead
to the idea of some kind of afterlife
or something continues.
It is possible or is it possible that
all these different cultures and all
these different people have these
concepts because maybe something does
happen.
Maybe some that's right.
Yeah.
It could be something that could
possibly happen to whatever we think of
as consciousness.
That's sort of what we think of as you
and I think most of our consciousness is
weighed down by life experiences and
genetics and our environment and all the
things that we carry around in our head
is memories.
And I mean this is a big part of what,
what your life is,
you know,
and at the core of all that is the self
is you are consciousness,
whatever that means,
right?
It's never been.
No one's ever been able to take
consciousness and a little,
we extracted it and we put in this
beaker and now we weighed it.
Consciousness is a 28 grams or whatever.
Remember that stupid thing that people
always think when you died,
right?
Yeah.
Twenty,
21 grams yet 21 grams.
But what?
Imagine if that was the case and before
that all happened,
you went and downloaded,
your brain does some super computer,
right,
so you got to use.
You got one that lives in hell on earth,
living forever,
never going to die.
Just one mundane trip to starbucks after
another and you just try it out.
You're trapped in a computer,
which is what Ray Kurzweil is saying.
Like what if like you would if they give
you the opportunity to be trapped into
computer,
but you're trapped in an iphone one
essentially once you're in,
you're in like you can either wait and
hang on for a few years and you will get
a really good computer.
We're thinking quantum computers are
going to go live around 20,
30,
20,
32,
but we can get you in now looking
pretty.
You're coughing a lot,
Mike.
I mean,
well it's like with the cryonics people
and I remind people,
you know,
you're being frozen on the worst day of
your life.
You know the,
they,
you died and you can't do it earlier
because the state treats it as a form of
burial legally.
So you can't be,
you can't get the treatment and the
fruit in the injected with the
antifreeze and all that before you were
actually dead or how they inject you
with antifreeze yet type of antifreeze
that,
the purpose of that while your dad.
So it doesn't really matter,
but the purpose is to keep the cells
from shattering the freezing process.
We'll do that.
So they've gotten much better about
that.
And what's actually frozen is this sort
of gelatinous mass that's,
that's vitrified.
It's called vitrification process.
So it's,
it's,
it's a little bit like a member of the
touring the bodies where they had the
dissected bodies and they were sort of
this hard plastic plasticine.
The plasticine.
Yeah.
So this vitrification is sorta like
that.
And then that's frozen.
And uh,
as far as we need,
as far as I'm concerned,
everyone frozen to date,
including Ted Williams in his head in
Arizona,
there will never be brought back.
Isn't Walt Disney frozen?
I trust that.
Then it turns out they alcor cryonics
foundation opened its doors and released
a press release the same day Walt Disney
died.
And these two stories that.
Yeah,
yeah,
that makes sense to Williams.
One is sad because they didn't have the
money for the whole body's took his
head.
All right,
fuck.
It actually isn't that expensive because
if you.
The way the way alcor and the other orgs
do it is you take out an insurance
policy on your life and you make them
the beneficiary of the insurance policy.
So if you started young,
you had say a quarter million dollar
insurance policy,
a few hundred dollars a year in
premiums.
He started super late.
The premiums would be much higher,
but it's not like you're shelling out a
quarter million dollars right at your
checkbook and then when you do die,
what happens if you get defrosted?
Because that has happened,
right?
Having done well.
Oh well what happens is as you look like
a bowl of melted strawberries that were
frozen,
it's just,
it's just much that happened to one of
the companies that does this.
They had a power outage,
right?
Yeah.
You don't want that.
I'm not sure whether in Alcor is in
Arizona.
I made.
That's a terrible place.
Shouldn't they be like in Antarctica and
there's other deeper issues with this
whole idea because if you're going to be
frozen for a thousand years or so,
what's to say that the state of Arizona
is going to be around where the
government or the company that keeps the
lights on?
Everything under water or anything.
Could anything transport your body and
some sort of one of the big Ole Electric
Tesla trucks.
Big Cooler.
It'll send you to Mars.
Yeah,
send me some new spot.
Yeah.
Cool.
Uh,
and again,
um,
would,
if they somehow jumpstarted the body,
would you wake up like you just had a
long sleep?
Would you still be in there?
I'm not at all sure that you wouldn't
just be something like if they,
if the memories weren't preserved very
well,
then it would just be a Zombie.
If you don't know who you are,
there's no point in doing it.
I think the idea is freeze you.
And then one day they'll have the
technology to throw you out and
everything's going to be amazing.
And there'll be able to reverse aging
and bring you back to when you're 18.
That's right,
yeah,
but here's the thing about memories,
what like if you do die and say if you
do go to heaven,
you have the memories of your life.
Are Those memories just like the
memories of today fallible and
squirreling.
Right,
and if they're not,
then that's not really you.
And if God resurrects you physically,
what's to stop you from aging and
getting Alzheimer's or whatever.
Well,
God's gonna prevent that by
reengineering you.
Well then that's not really me.
That's up there at some super human
transhuman.
I had a conversation with some friends
of mine who are Mormon and they couldn't
believe that I don't have religious
feelings and one of the things that this
lady said to me,
I'll never forget,
she goes,
you don't believe in afterlife.
How do you get up in the morning?
Literally what she said,
how do you get up?
And I go,
I love life here.
I enjoy this experience.
I am enjoying being here at dinner with
you guys.
I'm going to do some stuff tomorrow.
I've got planned out looking forward to
it.
I got like,
don't you enjoy your time?
Like does everything have to be for a
reward some place that you're not even
totally sure exist after we're done
here?
It's such a weird thing to say because I
don't think they even think about that
and I'd get seriously doubt.
She wakes up in the morning goes,
okay,
because there's an afterlife.
I'm feeling good about life and I'm
going to get up.
I doubt it.
I think it alleviates the pressure and I
think that's a big part of what it,
what it is for people.
It.
It alleviates the concern for the future
like,
Oh,
you don't have to worry.
God's got it.
God's going to take care of it.
Right?
Everything happens for a reason.
God's going to take everything does
happen for a reason after it happens,
right?
That's right.
Yeah.
After it's over,
you can go back and go,
yeah,
it happened for a reason,
so it became this and that became who I
am.
So it all happened for a reason.
That's right.
Okay.
Yeah,
you're right.
But of course it usually what they made
is somebody pulling the strings to make
it happen.
Not just the pathway that you happen to
have gone down.
Exactly.
They always mean that God has some
grand,
very mysterious plan and kind of see how
that feels good.
Like,
okay,
I'm not alone.
There's somebody watching that after me,
not just my spouse and my friends and
family,
but you know,
somebody out there somewhere and I can
see why that feels good.
So this is the problem atheists have,
you know,
it dot talks about this,
like what do you say to somebody that's
dying?
It's like the Ricky Gervais' movie,
the invention of line,
you know,
where he goes,
he tells his mom,
well,
you know,
you get,
you get a mansion,
everyone who dies gets a mansion,
a mansion.
Oh yeah,
it's great.
And he goes on and then 10 minutes later
in the movie,
he's the Messiah because this meme got
out.
You know,
it's a great story and you know,
so we,
we can't do that.
If you're honest,
you can't make up a story.
So what do you say?
So in secular humanist circles,
it was articles about that.
What do you say?
And it's hard,
you know,
you can't,
you can't promise it,
but,
you know,
reminding people of what a great life
they've had,
you know,
how much they've influenced the lives of
other people,
you know,
and so on.
That's really all we have.
And um,
you used the line from Woody Allen in
there,
you know,
who says I don't want to live on,
in my work I want to live on,
in my apartment.
Okay.
I understand.
And uh,
but we,
we don't get to do that.
No,
we do not.
And again,
I want to go back to what I said earlier
is that you are enjoying this partially
because it's temporary.
It's part of the thing about a day.
Like you don't want to stay up forever,
right?
You want to enjoy the day and then at
the end it's over.
And that day is a microcosm of your
life.
Yeah.
It's kind of fun to think,
okay,
I got eight hours here before,
you know,
it's dinnertime and,
and so on.
So I got to get my workout in and I get
to write this and I get to make these
calls.
And it's kind of fun to kind of see how,
if you can squeeze it all in.
Yeah.
And knowing that there is a time,
if it was a 20 hour window,
I,
you know,
I just started fucking around and like,
Eh,
get plenty of times I find I get more
done as a person who's very busy with a
family and children and all that stuff.
Right.
I feel like I get more done because I
don't have time to fuck off.
I very rarely have time to fuck off.
Yeah.
I've been distracted the last six months
or a year or so with a following twitter
feeds that send interesting articles to
read,
which are interesting articles.
There's a ton of really good content out
there.
And then podcasts,
your podcast,
sams and Dave Rubin and,
and,
and you know,
just like,
wow,
this is all good.
I really want to consume,
but wait a minute,
wait a minute,
I'm not getting my workout in,
I'm not doing this.
And it's like,
okay.
So it's a good problem to have.
It's a first world problem to have as
they say.
And I think what the transhumanists and
the Ray Kurzweil thank is heaven would
be something like that.
Just endless streams of content that you
enlist twitter feed.
That's true.
Maybe that's not good.
Yeah.
I don't know.
It could be hell yeah.
I don't know what he wants.
I mean I don't.
The living forever thing is very
problematic.
It's like what?
You are,
be so outdated.
Right?
You know,
you know,
100 years.
Yes,
totally.
I just.
And the downloading yourself into a
computer thing too.
What's to stop a guy like Kim Jong wound
from downloading himself 100 times or a
thousand or do it every day.
Well,
every day makes a new Kim Jong Il.
This is one reason that these cult
leaders,
they do try to do that through lots of
sex.
That is kind of what they're doing.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Wow.
Setting,
they're setting their genes out into the
future as much as they can.
Let me ask you this then.
What is that?
Why does that instinct exist?
Like is that a purely approcreation
instinct?
Yeah,
I think so.
Yeah.
So you think that's the religious cult
leader instincts?
It's based entirely on some ancient
reward system that's designed to get you
to gingiss con your jeans out throughout
the.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
You know,
there's A.
I have a chapter there and why?
Why do we have to die?
I mean,
what?
Why can't we just be programmed like
infants are and babies,
you know,
the cells divide rapidly and they're
super healthy.
I have a young son now,
he's 20 months.
You know,
when he gets a little cut,
you could practically watch it heal.
It's just incredible.
And yet when I get a cut at 63 and it
takes a couple of weeks to heal,
it's like,
why can't I?
Can't the system keep going?
And the answer is twofold.
And second,
law of thermodynamics,
entropy,
everything is running down and second
natural selection programmed us to stay
alive long enough to keep it,
get our children's children into the
reproductive age.
After that,
given that we have limited resources and
energy in the system we live in,
it's better to allocate the resources to
the third generation say,
rather than you,
you don't need to live 150,
200 years,
60,
70 years.
Your children's children are now in
their early twenties and having babies,
you're done.
As far as natural selection is
concerned.
Now I say it in a way like there's the
czar of the secretary of the treasury
that's allocating resources.
You know,
there's nothing like that.
It's just natural selection.
Selecting things for whatever's best for
survival to get genes into the,
into the future.
So this is Dawkins' argument in the
selfish gene that that the gene is the
is.
This is the thing we should be focused
on,
not the body.
That natural selection kind of operates
on the body,
the phenotype that that gets expressed
in a physical body,
but the body's are just survival
machines that the replicators build to
keep going.
So the replicators are immortal.
The species is a mortal.
In a sense.
Our genome is a moral.
That's why toxins called that river out
of Eden.
One of his book title that says that the
river out of Eden is eternal as long as
our species doesn't go extinct.
Uh,
we,
we live forever,
but you and I as a,
as just survival machines were just the
gene's way of keeping itself to the next
generation.
So you're really only good for maybe 60,
70 years for a human timescale.
You know,
your kids,
kids get to survival age,
you're done.
And this is the problem of that.
All the radical life extension has had
the whole system starts to fall apart at
around the same time,
like mid to late eighties.
Things start falling apart.
If you can make it into your nineties
and you're still reasonably healthy,
that's really good.
Maybe you had Mel Gibson and his doc on,
you know,
with the stem cells,
all that stuff is only going to push
this further further more of us to the
upper ceiling.
We're not going to break through that
upper sending about 120 without
something hugely,
completely re-engineered.
There may be a crisper technology that
re engineered the genome to stop all
this stuff from happening.
But you know,
we have 4 billion years,
well three and a half billion years or
so of life,
of that continuity of the genome and
it's all built into there.
And every single system,
every cell,
all parts of your yourself,
they're all going to age.
And so,
you know,
when people like Aubrey de grey,
I don't know if you know,
got that long.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
He's great.
I love this guy and I love that.
That beer is his favorite thing that he
thinks is going to be part of the
process.
Okay.
I'll have a few beers if this is going
to help and even if it.
That's okay.
Yeah.
That was one of the things that may be
most skeptical of him.
It was at the beer that's an amino
suppressant drinking poison.
Yeah.
I mean it's a mild poison.
That's delicious model.
That's not good to drink this shit all
day long.
I was like,
this is weird.
And I was talking to somebody that
interviewed him and said he was clearly
drunk,
like I was like,
really?
And she was like,
yeah,
I interviewed him.
He was drunk drinking beer and he was
drunk and she was like,
and it wasn't.
It wasn't late in the day either.
Started started is just gets hammered.
Does Science Fountain of Youth Very
early?
Yeah.
He's a fascinating guy too,
because he's not really much for
exercise either.
Now a nutrition,
a lot of these guys that are into this,
they don't.
To me,
they don't look healthy.
No,
no.
It's the one thing we know for sure in
terms of longevity to get you closer to
the upper ceiling and more of is don't
smoke.
Don't drink too much.
Exercise every day.
Especially Cardio,
you know,
and,
and just eat right.
Eat healthy foods.
Whole foods,
you know that I'm relieved to hear you
know that.
Meat and eggs and butter.
This is all okay now.
Good.
Because it always felt like this was a
balance with the salads.
Salads are good too.
What's good?
What's not good?
Sugar is the devil.
That's the worst.
That's right.
And it's amazing how.
Now I love listening to your podcasts
with Nina Teicholz.
Tie.
Shoulds.
Yes.
Because I totally related to the,
you know,
I went through my.
No meat stage and I just eat down in
these huge bowls of quaker Granola,
which is incredibly addictive because
it's sugar and this.
I was cycling a lot and I wasn't.
Not only was I not losing weight,
I'm putting weight on.
I got to like carrying around this extra
10 pounds,
but I'm eating granola.
It's healthy.
No.
Well,
especially the Granola that most people
bothered us.
Sugar just laced all over it.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people that eat things
that they think are healthy.
There's this great bread that my wife
brought home.
It was like a dave's super bread or some
shit like that.
I forget what it's called,
but I bit into it and I was like,
this is,
this is cake.
Yes.
This might as well be cake.
And then I looked at it and there's like
massive amounts of sugar.
Absolutely.
Oh,
okay.
I didn't even realize how much sugar is
in bread till my wife's from Cologne,
Germany,
Jennifer,
and you know,
they,
they have real bread in Germany.
I mean you pick up a loaf of bread,
it's like four pounds.
It's like a thing,
a lead because it's got nuts and it's
super heavy and rich and there's no
sugar and it tastes very different,
but once you get used to it,
it's way better.
Well,
it's also they're dealing with heirloom
wheat in most of the European countries.
What we've done from I guess the early
19 hundreds of slowly change what we
used to be into.
My friend Maynard explained it to me
because he has a restaurant and he get.
They grow pasta that's from heirloom
wheat and he said that the wheat that
you're getting today,
we have the same amount of acres.
You get a much higher yield is a bigger
plant.
It's a big fluffy thing and it also has
much more complex gluten's in it so
people have more of an issue digesting
it.
You're getting like a lot more gluten
insensitivity today than we've ever had
before and that's all because of this
manipulated wheat.
So we started buying pasta from Italy.
You can get heirloom pasta that's grown
in Europe and it just.
It tastes different.
It makes you feel different when you.
It doesn't feel like a brick in your
stomach.
Right?
I mean,
it's still pasta.
It's still carbohydrates.
It's,
it's not the best stuff for you,
but it's certainly better and it gives
your body a better or feeling,
right?
Yup.
Bread without sugar.
Pasta without sugar.
Yeah.
Well you're going to get some.
It's just,
it's different.
It's,
and you know,
bread like bread is just bread.
It's not good for you.
It's not.
I love that story from Gary Tubbs that
um,
you know,
when they started,
uh,
taking,
um,
when they started making the transition
from eating meat to eating carbohydrates
and it tasted like crap.
It's like people don't want to eat
cardboard,
so we got to put something in there to
make it taste good.
Sugar.
Yup.
He was like,
oh,
right.
That was like 19 sixties,
late fifties after Eisenhower had his
heart attack.
And then that whole meme of the dietary
fat equals a cardiovascular heart
disease.
Okay.
Well,
I'm sure you read the New York Times
article about how the sugar industry
bribe scientists to say that sugar was
the issue with heart disease and to take
the blame,
excuse me,
to take the blame off sugar and put the
blame on saturated fat.
It's stunning.
It's stunning how many people to this
day will just parrot that back and the
fact that saturated fat is terrible for
it,
right?
Like meanwhile,
it's no cholesterol terrible for,
you know,
it's actually the building blocks for
hormones,
right?
It's literally the substrate for
hormones,
right?
That's what your body is made of,
the cell,
the cell walls,
or you need cholesterol to build those.
Say that.
The people that like,
what are you talking about?
You're crazy.
Less going to kill you.
It's going to kill you.
Michael Shermer,
right?
Yeah.
It's weird.
Nina's book is excellent,
and then there's quite a few books.
Gary Tobbs book is excellent as well.
There's,
you know,
there's a lot of people now that are
shifting their diet over to,
you know me,
you can call it Paleo or Marxists and
calls it primal primal blueprint.
Essentially just eating vegetables and
fish and meat and eating healthy things,
eating Avocados and coconut oil and you
know,
and healthy fats and that's what your
body craves.
Right.
And once you get used to it,
one of the things that's incredibly
beneficial is I tell people I don't get
hungry during the day.
Like most people,
I'm not starving.
Right.
And I don't crash,
like I don't need an,
I don't need naps.
Like what,
what do you have for breakfast or before
you eat?
Before a workout or after I eat after a
workout when I like to do is fasted
cardio.
Usually run in the morning or do yoga in
the morning with no,
no food in my stomach.
So it's like 11 or 12 before you eat.
Or I had eggs and eggs for breakfast.
Yeah.
And Avocado and um,
you know,
like last night I had steak and I'm an
avocado.
Like I'm eating mostly that'll hold you
through the workout about 10 or 11 in
the morning and I'm fine now.
What we have after a workout,
um,
depends.
Maybe a protein shake.
I'm really depends entirely.
Today haven't worked out yet.
So I just had breakfast,
right,
but most of what I'm eating is whole
foods,
healthy whole foods.
I'd still eat plenty of salad.
I still yet,
but I very rarely I'll indulge and
carbohydrates,
like I had a cheeseburger from five guys
on Sunday.
Every now and then I'll dive in.
That's right.
I think if you're working out a lot you
can.
He can tolerate a little bit more of
that.
Yeah.
Just give yourself a little cheat day.
You feel better about it.
You don't feel.
You feel like you're constantly
depriving yourself.
But overall I feel great.
Yeah.
We do some long three hour bike rides up
in Santa Barbara where I live now.
There's a group at pretty seriously
effected by.
No,
no,
I was just north of that.
The firearms.
Yeah.
But I was trapped there,
you know,
it was like being on an island.
The only way out is to go five hours
north and around to get to La.
Really?
Yeah.
For about three weeks.
The only way to get to La is you had to
go up to Santa Maria,
take the one 66 over the five year
practically in Bakersfield and then five
south to la.
Yes.
Yeah.
So the one on one was shut down,
completely shut down and all that.
There's only like a feud side roads that
parallel and they were all close because
they were covered in mud and also all
the trucks and um,
and,
and equipment that construction
equipment to get the mud out of there.
They just opened it to a Sunday night.
That's incredible.
So for awhile they had fairies at a
ferry from Santa Barbara to Ventura.
Of course you take the ferry Ventura,
then you don't have a car.
Then you know,
you get an uber to la or something
crazy.
Mud slides were insane.
CDOT Oprah,
Oprah was there the next day.
I think she must've.
Helicopter didn't obviously,
but uh,
Mr. House by like 50 feet,
something like that.
Oprah is their magic.
We may have injured.
See,
we may have another western White House
in Santa Barbara,
the Reagan ranch where he had his
western White House houses north of
Santa Barbara.
You think Oprah is going to win?
She's going to run for president.
She,
I don't know if she's going to run,
but I.
The world we live in now.
She could.
When you think so.
She's a pretty good speaker.
She's not bad.
She's a good speaker.
Yeah.
This is what I always bring up with
Oprah.
Do you remember when Oprah was a big
supporter of the secret?
Oh,
totally.
Yes.
I know we've debunked her stuff because
she's always open to woo woo stuff.
She was super open to that.
She was,
we did the calculation.
She was like 50 then.
Yeah.
She wasn't a young,
dumb kid and didn't know any better.
Nope.
You know,
and uh,
I mean,
she's a living testimony to what you can
do if you put your mind to it,
you want,
use your intelligence and hard work.
And she had a television show that was
fun to watch and it was great for women.
It was like she sort of,
she filled a niche that wasn't,
wasn't filled before.
Yeah,
there's some.
Okay.
So we have to make a distinction between
the kinds of things that say a Tony
Robbins or maybe even a Jordan Peterson
would say,
like,
here,
here are some things you could do
that'll help you be more successful,
you know,
set your goals,
write them down every morning when you
get up,
you have a plan,
you know,
like Jocko says,
you don't have your running your workout
clothes ready to go so you're not
fumbling around and give up,
you know,
it's almost like you're betting on your
future self.
I know this is what I'm going to be like
in 12 hours,
so I'm going to do something now.
That's good.
Uh,
you know,
in Jordan has his book.
Here's the 12 things you gotta do to do
what?
Well,
to be successful.
Okay.
So,
you know,
Oprah Kinda,
I think did those things intuitively
just as a,
you know,
just what she did.
That's how she became successful,
which has nothing to do with.
If I tell the universe I want a
Lamborghini,
it's kind of up here in my driveway,
you know,
and then,
then the,
the other deeper problem with that was
that this implies that what if I'm not
successful?
You just weren't thinking positive.
You mean these poor people in Somalia or
even worse.
What about children with the disease?
So they thinking,
well,
yeah,
yeah.
It's no good.
So the idea that you,
your entire existence is based entirely
inside of your own imagination.
It's just preposterous.
There's a lot of random shit that's
going on in this world.
Some parts of the world get hit by
meteors.
Were they bad people there?
No.
Well,
how come?
How come Putin didn't get hit by a
meteor assassinating rivals and god is
still a.
It was just a lot of people out there
that are terrible people that just state
through.
That's right.
Somehow or another problem of evil.
Why do bad things happen to good people?
And good things happen to bad?
Sometimes they do.
Right?
The problem with the,
the secret is that if you're successful
and you know you have this story of I
just imagined it and I willed it into
being and look,
here I am,
you can do it too,
right?
I'm sorta how many people also willed it
into being.
It didn't work.
Like let's get the full numbers.
How many people daydreaming all day and
they never got that pony.
You know,
I call this the biography bias.
People write biographies of Steve Jobs.
Okay,
so here's the thing.
You enroll in a really elite college
dropout.
Move back to your parents' house.
It started a startup company in your
garage.
It works actually how many people did
this in the seventies and they did start
up companies and they went out of
business in three months or whatever.
You have to have a good product now and
no one writes a biography of them,
right?
So we only hear the hits,
forget the Mrs,
but at least those people,
even if they failed,
they took a shot at something.
They're trying to make something happen.
It fails.
They could try something else.
And maybe the third,
fourth,
fifth one will take,
but the idea of the secret is the most
preposterous thing ever was because
you're sitting around imagining that
you're going to will it into existence,
the perfect spouse,
the perfect home,
the perfect family,
and you would just sit and dream about
it and write it down and put pictures of
it up on the wall.
And then you would make it happen.
Like,
no,
you got to go do things,
you gotta to do it and to do things.
And it's this.
The one thing that keeps people from
achieving things is the actually going
out and doing things.
For whatever reason,
we have this blockade against action,
right?
People are terrified of the unknown,
just like we're terrified of death,
right?
Terrified of the unknown.
You have the role of chance is huge and
we don't,
uh,
we,
we forget to see the failures.
I was a ride the other day with a guy,
you know,
what do you do?
I'm a,
a venture
capitalist.
So what's the ratio?
I mean,
you have the,
you put in 200,000,
$500,000,
half pay.
What?
And he goes,
no,
90 percent fail because I get it.
I said,
you nine out of 10 companies,
you invest half a million or whatever
it's gone.
He goes,
Yep.
But the one,
you know,
the one I made $20 million dollars on,
more than makes up for the nine
failures.
Like,
Oh wow,
you know,
that's a high ratio.
So there's,
um,
I know there's research on entrepreneurs
and how risk taking you should be.
So entrepreneurs score high and risk
taking,
you know,
they're,
they're not risk averse.
Okay,
that's good.
But on the other hand,
some of them have what's called the over
optimism bias.
They just never give up.
This is,
this is the idea.
I'm sticking with it.
I'm going to keep pouring money into it.
No,
dude,
nine out of 10 fail.
Just keep trying until you get the one.
You at some point you got to be a risk
taker,
but not too crazy.
You gotta know when to bail.
You got to know when to bail.
Yeah.
Yup.
Well that's a crazy way to make a
living.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
on other people to.
Oh,
I know.
Do you ever watch shark tank?
Sometimes my wife and I've been binge
watching shark tank.
The stuff that people come up with,
you know,
I mean it's like some of them are just
ridiculous,
but I think it's kind of like American
idol where they get let those ridiculous
people on because it's entertaining.
It's half the fun is watching people's
preposterous ideas through that.
The other night he had a little of this
little chip thing he put over the
computer,
um,
the camera so that,
you know,
the NSA or whoever can't watch you watch
in it.
And he's like,
okay,
so here's the thing,
you know,
I'm going to sell it for nine 95 and if
we get one percent of the market,
blah,
you know,
we're all going to be billionaires.
And then one of the sharks said,
what?
You just put a piece of tape over there.
I,
I think I saw mark Zuckerberg put a
piece of duck tape on his,
over the camera.
Oh yeah.
You know,
or,
or somebody else said it'd be fun if you
had a little thing he put over it.
And there was an image on the inside,
it was like this,
you know something.
Imagine that the type
cyber person that would have to be
sitting around all day waiting for you
to turn your laptop camera on.
Come on,
let me see what you're doing.
And they must have algorithms that just
look and scan and try to find it.
I don't know.
I could only imagine what's up and stuff
that came out over the weekend.
I will tell you about that.
Snowden was really leading the sound of
your,
oh,
the Nsa knows who you are,
just by the sound of your voice.
And their tech predates apple and Amazon
or report on the intercept,
citing documents leaked by former NSA
contractor,
Edward Snowden revealed that the NSA has
highly refined [inaudible] voice
recognition software.
The agency's technology dates back more
than a decade and was instrumental in
helping to identify Saddam Hussein after
the invasion of Iraq.
The reports dated,
uh,
your voice were just in the room with
your laptop,
or you mean on the phone?
Supposedly it can now.
They can use almost any microphone
that's connected to the Internet.
Every letter in your voice,
they're the recognition they have is
better than a face print or a
fingerprint.
So if they wanted to find young Jamie
that could get you or laptop already
have it.
Wow.
This is saying or you have had it and
don't worry about it.
Like there's almost nothing you can.
What is your thoughts on snowden and
then who's the other guy?
I have A.
I have a bad feeling about Julia.
Jay have a good feeling about snowden.
Do you have everybody had a good feeling
about a sausage?
Yeah.
Trump got into office.
No,
no.
The stuff before that,
I didn't care for him,
but I saw a snowden made an appearance
at Ted was the last 10 I went to in
Vancouver.
Then they rolled them out on a computer,
big screen and there he was in Russia or
somewhere.
Right.
But the points he made were similar to
that of Daniel Ellsberg and the Pentagon
papers.
It's like we should know what our
government is doing.
We don't have to know everything.
You don't have to share the nuclear
codes with uni,
but you know,
at some point,
you know,
there's some line there how much freedom
versus security and,
and uh,
you know,
there's too much stuff going on.
Even in the Obama administration,
that administration of transparency,
this is when a lot of this stuff was
happening and say,
wait a minute.
I thought it was Bush that was doing
this kind of stuff,
but when we have to remember that Edward
Snowden went into hiding during the
Obama administration,
one of the worst administrations ever on
record for,
with whistleblowers.
Right.
Which is really crazy because if you go
look at the hope and change website when
it initially existed,
one of the big promises was protection
for whistleblowers exposing illegal
activity and that's just not true yet.
I think he should be allowed to come
back.
Yes.
He doesn't have to be.
Worship is a hero.
It's just like this.
He said brave person before him.
We didn't know we were talking about any
of this stuff.
I didn't know about this stuff.
While there was some,
there was an NSA contractor from many
years ago who brought this stuff up and
he was sort of dismissed.
What is his name?
He was the original NSA contractor that
brought this up,
I want to say in 2011.
Um,
probably could see him in my mind.
I can't remember his name.
That's it.
Bill Binney.
I'm not sure who that pull that pull
that guy out.
Young Jamie I just read was the original
guy.
Bill Benny,
the original NSA whistleblower on
snowden nine slash 11 and illegal
surveillance.
This was,
he became incredibly concerned post nine
slash 11 when they started,
uh,
doing a lot of this in the initial work
on computer surveillance and all this
stuff they were doing.
And he bailed and interesting.
And you started talking about it openly
and publicly.
And then snowden came out after that.
And the snowden thing was where people
got all [inaudible] look what we're
really got a chance to understand,
oh,
this is actually happening right now.
This is a real thing,
right?
Yeah.
I do think the government does overreach
with their security theater.
You know,
we're at orange level today,
remember that believable.
It doesn't happen anymore.
What happened to that?
And yet the number of Americans that die
from foreign terrorism.
I mean,
there are some of the domestic terrorist
if you want to consider mass public
shootings in that category,
but foreign terrorists coming here to
kill Americans.
Uh,
uh,
I mean,
what,
what is,
is,
is less than bathtub.
Drownings are weightless and they like
lightning struck double lightening
strikes or something.
I mean,
it's just nothing.
It's like shark attacks.
Yeah.
Alright.
It's just why are we spending billions
and billions of dollars on this?
It's because they put.
That was.
They could,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's like the proverbial elephant
repellent you'd ever.
Since we put the repellent here,
not a single elephant is going to end.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Well,
Michael Sherman,
we're Americans.
We don't want to get caught with our
pants down.
I understand.
And you know,
it's there.
I just read Daniel Ellsberg's new book,
the Doomsday Machine.
This is on nuclear deterrence.
He's against nuclear.
He thinks nuclear deterrence as a,
as a rational strategy is,
is a longterm mistake because of the
possibilities of error,
which,
you know,
it's all good points,
but he has,
I'm not sure why it took so long to
bring this book out.
He's got his notes when he worked for
the State Department in the fifties,
and then the rand corporation in the
early sixties during the Kennedy
Administration of the kinds of
calculations that go,
our own government was making about how
many people we were willing to kill in
defense,
you know,
hundreds of millions of Russians just,
she was like,
oh,
it's like the scene from um,
uh,
Dr strangelove where George C dot Scott,
you know,
he's like,
I'm not saying we wouldn't get our hair
mussed,
but 20,
30 million tops.
And that's actually real.
That's the kind of numbers they were
throwing out.
Yeah.
You can't leave a human being without
much responsibility and power.
And I think that's the bottom line when
it comes to this NSA surveillance things
that all these government agencies are
populated by human beings and human
beings should not have that kind of
power over other human beings that are
just citizens.
Right?
Because they're just the,
the ability to check all the snowden
talked about people being able to check
in on their exes and read their emails
and they were doing things like that.
And this is when Obama was like,
no,
this is just better data.
It wasn't just metadata,
man,
whoever.
They were looking at everything and it,
that's,
that's something we should know about.
And we didn't until snowden and now this
poor guy has to live in Russia.
Yep.
Nope,
I think he should be brought back for
sure.
But could he be,
he would have to do something awesome
for trump.
Might be after trump.
I Dunno,
I dunno.
Maybe.
Maybe he jumps out that of all people.
It's Putin who's protecting it.
It's like,
wait a minute,
what?
I know it's weird.
Well,
he's probably helping,
but.
But when he makes.
If you watched the Ted Ted talk,
Ted to interview,
Chris Anderson was just talking to them
on the stage when from undisclosed
location in Russia,
you can't come up totally reasonable.
This is what democracy.
Here's a democracy.
This is what we live in.
Citizens need to know some things.
Not everything came up totally rational.
He did a great podcast with Neil
degrasse Tyson and he came off very
rational there as well.
Oh,
I didn't know neal,
uh,
interview.
Um,
look,
we,
we don't agree to that kind of
surveillance.
That's,
that's very orwellian.
It's not what we want,
right?
This is not,
you're not stopping terrorism.
No.
You just spying on people.
And also people are rightly concerned
that anything that they find could be
used against you if you are a political
opponent of theirs or if there's
something that you're trying to oppose
and they go,
Hey,
well,
you know,
we found out the year in the cuckold
porn buddy or whatever it is.
You know,
it's just,
there's too much tennis stuff.
Nixon did with the,
um,
with the hoover Jesuit horror and the
FBI.
Well,
I think whoever did it on his own right,
he did,
it predicts.
It was a fascinating character,
you know,
crossdresser as mind freak,
just like spying on everybody just to
try to hide his own secrets.
Really amazing.
But there's an example of one person
flawed human,
like everyone else given all this power
and imagine what hoover would do today
with the Internet.
I mean he,
he,
Oh God.
Arguably more flawed than normal human
beings.
And I think that goes back to the thing
that you were talking about with these
cult leaders.
It's like humans should not have power
over other humans,
right?
When they do,
they do terrible things and they abuse
that power and they mean it's the
responsibility that one would have to be
able to do that.
George C dot Scott thing and say,
God,
20 million,
30 million,
no big deal.
It a few people in Chicago,
right?
I mean,
that is,
that's a crazy thing for a human being
to have at their fingertips.
Yep.
And the other problem is bureaucracy,
any large organization,
but especially bureaucracies,
their tendency is to keep alive.
We gotta keep our,
keep our jobs and uh,
and,
and the moment you set up a government
agencies,
it's really difficult to shut it off.
Yeah,
almost impossible because you have real
people with jobs and mortgages and
families that I get to keep my job,
so we have to justify why we need our
department and so on.
And it just always builds that way.
But that is the big issue with big
government is it just grows bigger.
It does,
it never shrinks.
They never say,
Oh,
you know what?
We don't need the irs.
Right.
This is nonsense.
We just,
you know,
we realized that if we don't have the
irs,
we have to pay so many less people that
we can actually get less money in taxes
from folks.
Right.
What,
what?
Yeah.
No,
it's A.
Yeah,
it's just a huge problem.
I don't have a good solution to it.
Well,
it brings me back to the last word of
the title of your book.
The scientific search for the afterlife.
Immortality and Utopia.
Utopia.
Yeah.
Hope is what we're always looking for.
Yeah,
totally.
And it doesn't exist.
It can't ever exist.
Not even in principle because there is
no right society because we have so much
variation in our interests and needs and
wants and your abilities and you know
the idea of programming by fed from the
top down,
this is what we're going to do and it's
going to work or else you're out and
this.
The problem with utilitarianism is get
you that utilitarian calculus of the
greatest good for the greatest number
and we know what that is and are
standing
in our way.
You are preventing utopia,
so we are going to eliminate you.
You know this is the famous trolley
experiment,
a thought experiment.
You know the trolleys hurdling down the
tracks about to kill the five workers.
You're at the switch.
If you throw the switch,
it'll go down a sidetrack.
It'll kill one worker.
Would you throw the switch?
Skilled the one to save the five,
the five?
We're going to die if you don't do
anything.
So we did throw the switch some.
Most people say they would,
that you can go on the website and do
this yourself and son who's on track.
Yeah,
it really does.
It's rush limbaugh on this one track she
imagined and five school kids.
Yeah,
with massive potential for the future.
But uh,
so now most people said they would flip
the switch,
but in an interesting twist on that.
So if,
if,
if you're standing on a bridge over the
track and the train is hurdling down the
tracks about to kill the five workers
and standing next to you is a great big
guy.
Would you hip check him off?
Boom.
He lands on the tracks.
SPLAT.
He's killed by the train,
but it stops it and saves the five
workers.
Now most people say I got to physically
grab them and throw them up.
Yeah,
no,
I,
I couldn't do that.
So it's something to do with.
It engages the emotional part of the
brain that actively killing somebody is
way harder than passively killing.
So if you only have to put,
if you're at a 52 bomber,
35,000 feet up,
you only have to press the button to
release the bombs.
Not so
heart,
but that's even more actively doing it
than a drone.
The drone,
which apparently is a giant issue for
the drone pilots,
apparently they suffer from really weird
Brill Esd even though they're in Arizona
doing it in a rack or whatever.
Yeah,
the nightmares.
I mean,
they're pretty intense.
Interesting.
I had not,
I hadn't heard that.
Yeah,
I mean,
if you're looking at a screen and you're
seeing someone on the other side of the
planet,
you know,
you're in Nevada,
right?
And some military base,
And you're hitting that button and
you're watching the screen.
You're seeing some,
you know,
infrared or black night vision,
right?
This'll slamming into the person that
you were just observing
movie about that,
that was like the trolley problem than
it was maybe two years ago.
Um,
where,
um,
the decision is to be made.
Well,
the setup is we know that the terrorists
and are making a bomb inside this
building and we can get a drone there
to,
to hit it.
And so they're about to do.
This is toward the beginning of,
they're about to do this.
And this little girl walks into the
scene and she's selling bread.
I think it's in Afghanistan or Iraq.
So she's on the corner so she will be
killed and it's like,
oh,
okay,
maybe we could come around from the
other side and then she won't be in
there doing all these calculations.
But now there's some other people over
here.
So how many people innocence should we
kill because we know that the terrorists
are going to,
if they complete their bomb bomb,
a suicide bomb,
they're going to go to a mall and killed
300 people or whatever.
So they,
those,
you know,
how these
government agencies think about those
calculations,
you know,
we,
we got to stop the bad guys,
but how many good people are we willing
to kill to prevent them from killing
even more?
We think maybe if they do this and then
it gets murky from there.
Well Mike Baker,
who's a former,
a big wig at the CIA,
have talked to him several times on the
podcast.
One of the things that he says that's
done by lawyers,
right?
That's right.
Because there,
there's,
there's legal precedence about
collateral damage that came from the
Nuremberg laws and they're,
you know,
there's some questionable stuff.
We were doing,
I mean,
I think it's justified second world war,
but you know,
the mass bombing of Hamburg and
addressed in this didn't slow the Nazi
or machine at all,
but the idea was that,
well,
the citizens will rise up and kill
Hitler.
No,
they,
you know,
that you can't.
And in that kind of society you just
don't have that kind of access or power.
And uh,
you know,
this was like when in the first Iraq
war,
you know,
we'll,
we'll stop short,
you know,
Bush senior said we're going to stop
short and let Saddam's own people taking
them out and have their own regime
change and then we'll support the new
regime and it just didn't work out that
way.
So they are,
the calculations get messy.
I got kind of sidetracked.
The problem with Utopian idea is that
utilitarian calculus.
If,
if most people will agree that it's okay
to kill one to save five,
why not kill 1 million to save $5
million?
That's genocide.
And that is the calculator calculations
that genocidal,
mass murderers make know that are our
German society would be great except for
those Jews,
you know,
the backstab,
the backstabbers who,
who ruined us in the first world war.
Now we can just get rid of them.
It's going to be great.
And every genocide is based on that kind
of utilitarian calculus.
However emotional driven it is.
And it's,
it's interesting when you look at the
numbers from drone attacks,
it's some high,
80,
90 percent of innocent people are
killed,
right?
The casualties,
um,
when you look at it in terms of what the
actual targets that we're looking for
versus the actual people that were
killed,
right?
Collateral damage.
There's a tremendous amount of
collateral damage.
And that's not something that we would
ever accept from one guy.
Say if we had one guy with a howitzer
and he just went in there and he says,
blasting women and children to get to
the guy that's in the top of the
building,
there would be no fucking way.
No going back,
I as a murderer,
he's a monster.
But if one guy in Nevada presses a
button and some hellfire missiles come
shooting out of a flying robot and they
slam into that building and kill
everybody,
including this one terrorist that we
were after,
except it.
Right?
So in game theory,
there's this problem of this sort of
sliding scale that,
okay,
I know it's like the milgram shock
experiment of 15 bolts at a time.
You know,
before you know it,
you're throwing 450 volts and it is
subject.
You couldn't get somebody to do that
initially.
But if you do it incrementally,
you know,
the,
the kind of hoping,
well if I hold out and just do one more,
maybe the end.
And it's like this with these kind of
utilitarian calculus.
Okay,
I know I probably shouldn't be doing
this,
you know,
these collateral damage or the.
But if we can.
But if we keep going,
we'll end the war and then that'll stop
the other kind of killing.
We do want to stop but it.
But it's always so messy that it takes
much longer than you think.
So you can kind of see the logic like,
okay,
I don't know if you watch Ken Burns'
documentary series,
the Vietnam War,
but it kind of felt like that the whole
time,
like this is when we see at the end,
it's like God,
this was like a task strappy,
but at every step,
you know,
Kennedy than Johnson and Nixon is like,
okay,
we can't give up now.
You know,
the sunk cost fallacy,
you know,
we put all this in there,
just one more month and then we'll get
out and then the month comes like,
okay,
we're not going to wait another month,
another year.
And then before,
you know,
you got 58,000 dead and it's like okay,
this just didn't work.
And I think that happens more often
because it's always messier.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
I mean,
war itself is an incredibly messy
business.
Do you know it's,
it's,
it's outlawed.
It was outlawed in the Paris peace
agreements of 19,
27.
War is illegal.
So a great book called the
internationalists.
It gives the history of how this came
about and that and the reason for it.
So they gave them the whole history
going all the way back to when war
became legal and it goes all the way
back to this,
uh,
Spanish and Dutch conflict they were
having.
And I forget who did what,
but a Spanish ship confiscated a Dutch
ship and took all that stuff.
And uh,
and then there was like a legal battle
about this and whichever side,
I think it was,
the Spanish said,
no,
actually,
uh,
we were,
we were at war and if you're at war,
it's okay to be a pirate and kill people
and stuff like that.
And so,
um,
this Hugo grosses,
legal scholar wrote all this treaties
that got laid down that said this is
when war is legal.
It's perfectly okay to kill other people
and take their stuff if you're at war.
So what does that mean to be a war?
You know,
so then it's legal,
it's all,
it's all done by lawyers.
Like,
okay,
this is what it is.
And we have lived with that ever since.
So in the 19,
27,
the Paris peace or even said,
okay,
you know,
we're going to stop that war is illegal
now obviously this didn't stop Hitler
and imperial Japan and so on.
But at least now a leaders have to
justify it.
It's like a Bush had to go to the UN and
get his coalition of the willing.
And that's when Colin Powell to say,
Oh yes,
we know about the yellow cake and that
Saddam Hussein wants nuclear weapons it.
I mean,
why would anybody bother with all that
stuff?
In the old days they just invade,
you know,
I came,
I saw,
I conquered it,
took my stuff,
and now you have to say I came,
I saw I was just standing there minding
my own business and he punched me.
So I invaded in.
You at least have to do that.
It's sort of like what we were talking
about earlier that the world today,
I mean their consciously recognizing
that there are more rules and that
society is a much more complex and safer
place to be and they want to protect
that progress in some way.
And that's what the rules of war in
comparison to 2000 years ago.
Right?
So that's a good thing.
Yeah.
I mean,
it doesn't stop everybody,
but even Kim,
John Wooten,
I kind of have a feeling that maybe I'm
naive that it's just deterrent for him.
He wants to take a place at the table
where he's respected.
His country is not going to be invaded.
And uh,
this is sort of a,
a Noam Chomsky argument that I usually
make,
but if you look at how America treats
other countries,
if they have nukes,
we leave them alone.
If they don't,
we do whatever we kind of feel like.
So from his perspective,
it could be those Americans because you
see,
they make arguments like this,
these Americans are evil.
Why?
Look they invaded this country.
They made that they've been in,
you know,
a dozen wars and just never ending.
This is who they are.
We're going to get new books and they're
gonna they're not gonna fuck with this
ever again.
And maybe that's,
maybe he'll just stop and go,
that's it.
Okay.
You leave me alone.
I'll leave you alone.
I don't agree with Noam Chomsky on
everything,
but I'm,
I'm very happy there's someone like him
out there who's a brilliant guy that's
as far left as you can get.
Yeah.
He's way out there.
I think it's important to balance these
intellectual disagreements and you know,
you need a super smart far left.
He guy wearing a sweater.
Excellent moves.
Right?
Well,
I agree.
So that's why we have to have free
speech and open dialogue and debate with
the guy over here to counter the guy,
you know.
So that's my instead of like
authoritarian left.
Well why are they there?
Because there's an authoritarian,
right?
Yes.
The problem is we expect that from the
right.
So this is why we're going through what
we're going through now.
It's kind of a surprise.
Wait a minute.
The liberals are doing this.
Well,
it's fairly recent.
Yeah.
You know the silencing of people you
disagree with and also the really
disingenuous labeling of people's Nazis
or a neo Nazis are white supremacist
just because they simply don't line up
with your beliefs of state and it's a
conscious decision to do that.
It's this isn't like an accidental
mislabeling,
we don't really know what the person's
motives and who they are.
No,
you're just trying to diminish whatever
position they have so that your side
wins and I think a lot of people feel
justified by it because of the current
administration and it just seems like
we're on a God damn pirate ship now.
I mean,
it seems like when you're seeing what's
going on with the erosion of the EPA and
the decision to start drooling,
really,
he made a sweeping decision that you
could drill anywhere.
Right?
Go ahead offshore.
Go ahead.
Just start drilling that ocean.
The fish oil baby.
Come on,
I'll be in my gold bathroom.
Giant gold chandelier over the toilet.
Guy Is crazy.
It's just a strange time.
It's like something out of a movie.
Oh,
it's way crazier than something out of a
movie.
If there was a president that was this
nuts in a movie,
you would say,
that's too over the top.
We played a video yesterday of trump
that looked at 24 different things that
trump said he was the best at nobody.
Nobody.
Nobody loves women more than I do.
Nobody loves Mexicans more than I do and
nobody.
Nobody's better at foreign policy than
trump uses himself in the third person
who saw like oprah as a president,
can we just have like professional
experts that work in this area that know
what they're doing,
even if they're not celebrities?
Well,
I'm,
I'm a firm believer that that position
is almost always abused and that will,
we really need instead of like one
person is like a council of why the
tribunal or something like that.
18 super smart people that have to write
papers on all these different decisions
that they make and I'd be happy with it.
With the tribe instead of a president,
you have three people,
you elect him and then for anything to
happen to it,
the three have to agree,
but even three because the FCC,
they.
They took out net and it was only five
people.
Five unelected people.
That's a good point.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Maybe 18.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I don't.
Well,
you need an odd number so you don't have
a tie breaker.
Yeah.
We had Jessica Rosenworcel,
his last name from the FCC,
she was one of the five that voted for
net neutrality.
She wanted to keep it in place and she
was on two weeks ago,
something like that.
And describing to us like what the
situation is like and how there's only
five people and they're not elected and
they get to decide how,
how did they get that?
They're appointed,
appointed by the president.
Um,
I don't know if they're appointed by
trump or maybe they are holdovers from
apparently easy to stack.
Is that what she said?
President Obama or trump says,
uh,
appointed by the president and confirmed
by the Senate for five year terms.
Okay.
There you go.
So these are new folks then.
Okay.
Yeah.
And they decided,
no,
let's just give all the money in the
corporation.
So instead them just block websites and
get crazy with throttling in writing.
Right.
It's a weird time for this.
Yes.
Right.
So back to the utopia.
Societies are messy and the only,
the only Utopian type system would be
one that there is no system.
You'd have checks,
just nothing but checks and balances
because these catch basins of power,
again,
back to the colts,
they inevitably form and anybody wants
more power if they can get it.
It's just human nature,
right?
It's human nature.
You it go back to where we're social
primates bases.
The alpha male is going to,
if he can get there,
he's going to stay there for as long as
he can and the Beta males are going to
try to under undermine and from out from
underneath this constant struggle.
Again,
there are two kinds of men.
Those would loaded revolvers and those
who did so well.
That's why you know this,
again,
sort of a horizontal bottom up.
Networking systems is one way to try to
counter the hierarchical power
structures.
It's not,
it doesn't always work,
but now as someone who spends so much
time looking for actual truth and facts
and scientific data,
how concerned are you about the media
today?
Because this,
this term fake news,
weird world of,
of attacks on journalism and then even
journalism itself falling short and then
journalism in many venues trying to keep
up with the Internet and putting out
these salacious click baity headlines
even like established media sources or
doing some sleazy shit now.
Yeah,
it's a concern for sure.
We have stay on top of it but,
but there are solutions to this,
like politifact for example,
where they're not the only site snopes
also ranking the factual basis of a
speech in real time.
And you can go on like politifact is
trump's given a speech or during the
campaign when they were all giving
speeches and they would rank them,
you know,
from,
true.
Mostly true,
partially false,
mostly faults,
pants on fire.
I love their ranking system.
And uh,
you know,
trump,
trump got a lot of pants on fire.
Yeah.
Uh,
so at least there's a counter to it.
And now those sites are becoming pretty
popular.
Um,
they're kind of a form of clickbait
themselves.
Let's go there and find out how many
times this guy lied in his speech.
So it would have been nice if we
would've had that say in the Nixon
administration or the Johnson
administration like the Gulf of Tonkin,
if this could have been,
you know,
a whistleblower and in called and put
out there so that we didn't drag
yourselves into the Vietnam war even
deeper.
My thought,
and this is a very,
a paranoid thought,
is that all this is inevitably opening
us up to the truth chip to the mind,
reading the chip.
But if things are going to get so
chaotic that we're going to say,
you know what,
just hit me with the chip.
I can't fucking take this anymore.
I don't know who's right.
Fox News says one thing.
CNN says another slide it in slide.
I want in my forearm right here.
Yes.
Solution.
It might literally be like nature's way
of allowing us to slowly accept the
symbiotic relationships with this.
This new artificial intelligence.
I think webster's just this last week
voted,
uh,
it was alternative facts is the word of
the year phrase of the year for 2017 for
the year before that,
it was fake.
Fake news with Sean Spicer said
alternative facts.
Right.
It was forced to try to like Kellyanne
conway after the inaugural.
A,
uh,
size of the audience.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
he said,
look at a picture.
Uh,
it's not as big as a.
well,
that's where.
Did you get that number?
That was an alternative fact.
Yeah.
They seem to like keep her locked up
more now.
She seems to be less less.
She just keeps stuffing her foot in her
mouth.
Yeah.
Well,
they all have to because the end of the
boss sends him out to tell them this.
Okay.
Can you imagine that's poor Sean Spicer
guy when he talks about it now it's like
a guy who's just been freed from prison.
Right?
Well,
he's probably making a lot of money on
the lecture circuit now.
Oh,
I can imagine.
Yeah,
probably.
It's probably a very lucrative,
but if you look at governments,
you know,
centuries past or thousands of years
ago,
they,
you know,
there was lying and corruption and all
that.
Oh,
that's,
that's old.
Yeah.
It's just now it's so blatant,
the yellow press.
I mean,
where did that come from?
That was,
you know,
the whoever told.
No,
it was hearst,
William Randolph.
First you gave me the war and I'll
supply you the photographs or whatever.
Yeah.
So you know that that's fake news.
That's literally affect news.
The sinking of the Maine.
Let's go to war.
Well,
you know what actually happened again?
Gulf of Tonkin.
Yeah.
That Vietnam War.
Documentary series.
I just wanted to put my head in the oven
after that and turn the gas.
I was like,
you know,
this went on for so long,
so many years.
What did we in Afghanistan,
I was 16 years now.
Vietnam war.
It wasn't quite that long,
but if you look back to where it started
in the fifties when we.
We weren't at war,
we were sending advisors there,
you know,
this kind of stuff.
It's just a,
it's so depressing.
We like to think of our government is
having enough checks and balances.
I think we need more.
I would like to think of our
civilization as being something that
aspires to a higher standard.
Some like something that is more
advanced because we've learned from the
lessons of the thousands of years of
written history and we we aspire to a
greater set of values.
So one of the things I like about Elon
Musk's,
let's go colonize Mars in addition to
the technological problems.
How will they set up lift?
There's 100 people.
There are a thousand,
10,000.
What kind of government are they going
to have?
What kind of me just maniacs and we'll
do.
It was so crazy to die on Mars.
It's probably not going to be your
average typical a human.
You imagine you're going to take a six
month spaceship visit through through
the cosmos to land on a planet that
you're going to die on.
You will never come back coming back,
unless they are so smart.
They figure out a way to build a rocket
and shoot back,
which they probably won't know but that.
But,
so if you went in,
you were advising like what kind of
government would you set up or you know,
sort of social organization to prevent
people from stealing other people's
stuff that we got to work cooperatively
to plant a potato things and question,
how do you do that?
You know,
we have thousands of years of
experiments,
but you know,
it's,
they're all messy.
Yeah.
No one's ever done it.
Right.
Which is again,
the utopian.
Yeah,
I mean,
is it different to have,
you know,
10 people,
100 people,
1000,
10,000,
you know,
there's a scaling effect where it
becomes more efficient the more people
you have.
But on the other hand,
then you get these power,
you know,
catch basins of power that grow and
become corrupt.
That's gotTa happen on Mars.
It's going to happen.
And also the community gets fractured
because you don't know these people
anymore and you get 5,000 people.
There's no way you can know 5,000
people,
$500.
Right?
There's Mike.
Hey Mike.
Yeah,
that's right sally.
You know those people,
you get 5,000.
You're like,
who's that guy just flew here?
He's from Chicago,
now,
those on Mars,
but you know,
even small hunter gatherer groups,
they have conflicts all the time.
They get to sit down in the dirt area in
the Commons ground and talk about it.
And then you stole this pig and the pig
died and now you alma pig.
Okay,
go get your pick.
we're going to settle it.
But what happens when someone dies?
You know,
it's like,
okay,
you owe 10 pigs.
You know,
they,
they had these calculations like this is
the equivalent of a life is 10 pigs and
uh,
that's going to happen no matter what
planet we're living on.
Did you get any personal insight?
I'm sure you do have to.
Every book you read,
you read or you write rather.
But did you get any unique personal
insight into this?
I did at the last chapter is on what
does it mean to live a fulfilling on
inspiring happiness,
a fulfilled life?
If there's no afterlife,
there is no god,
whatever.
Or even if there is,
it doesn't.
Again,
it doesn't really matter because we live
in this world,
so it turns out there's research that
shows that striving for happiness is the
wrong metric.
That's the wrong goal,
that striving to live a purposeful,
meaningful life is what we should be
after and that often entails doing
things that don't make you happy.
They're not fun,
they're not pleasurable.
So like for example,
when you work out,
you know,
it's not fun and in a sense of like a
morphine drip,
you know,
I'm getting a lot of pleasure from this.
Afterwards,
you get a sense of endorphins and you
feel better about yourself.
Um,
and so like there's research showing
that if you go out for drinks with your
friends to enter and so on,
that's fun.
It's pleasurable,
but it's short term.
A caretaking for a parent,
for example.
This shows that this is not fun at all.
I've done this.
Two of my four parents,
I had step parents and this was not fun.
It wasn't pleasurable.
I didn't enjoy it,
you know,
schlepping my dad around to doctors and
hospitals and you know,
I was just drained by the end of the day
doing this,
but I felt better about myself.
So it turns out the research shows that,
you know,
if you have more longterm goals both
forward and back,
forward goals,
back reflecting on your past,
what you've done,
not oriented toward being happy,
but being,
you know,
sort of leading a purposeful,
driven life.
That's what makes people feel better
about their lives.
And really that's all we can do.
And it's enough.
It's enough to sort of feel like my life
was well worth living.
It's worth getting up in the morning
without the promise of an afterlife.
You don't need that just like this life.
I can make a difference.
I can get up this morning,
do something that I may not enjoy it
quite so much,
but you know,
working out,
you know,
like I do my three hour bike ride,
it's so good to get up at.
I got to get up at 6:30 in the morning.
They roll out at seven.
It's cold,
partially dark,
it's like I got to bundle up and then
they gotta strip close off as I go,
so I have to figure this all out and
it's not fun.
But you know,
after,
after the ride I'm like,
I really feel great that I did this and
yeah,
I had fun with my buddies,
but it's not fun.
Like,
you know,
I had a drink with my friends and that
was fun.
That's a different kind of fun.
So.
And that funds okay,
two times balance,
but it shouldn't all be the fun,
right?
Yeah,
I mean they're full meaningful,
right.
There are people that do that.
So I talk about Diana Niad who I knew
back in the 19 eighties when I was doing
race across America,
the transplant on a bike race and Diana
worked for why we're live sports and
they covered the race.
I would talk to her a lot.
She's in the back of the truck with the
camera crew.
I'm riding along and uh,
she's a really interesting person.
She's an atheist,
you know,
she did the Cuba to Florida swim.
She's an ultra marathon swimmer and uh,
she failed to make it back in her
twenties and she came back when she
turned 60 and said I'm going to go for
this again.
And uh,
it took her four years and I think for
tries to do it,
but she did it.
So she appears on Oprah's super soul
Sunday show she had for awhile and um,
and Oprah's asking her will,
how do you find on and you know,
and meaning,
you know,
what do you believe?
Well,
I'm an atheist and she described how,
how are awestruck she is about the
universe and life and what science has
told us.
And Solomon,
Oprah says something like,
well,
I don't see how you can be an atheist if
you're in,
if you're on inspired.
And then she says,
I,
I don't see why those are in
contradiction.
I mean,
the whole,
you know,
living a meaningful life and being
engaged in the world and other people
that is spiritual,
that is inspiring,
that you know,
you don't need God for that.
And it was sort of an interesting
exchange because Uber's was reflecting
kind of a common theme that people have.
You need God to have a meaningful life.
And Diana's whole point was,
no,
you don't.
You just have to be engaged with the
world in some meaningful way.
And that's enough.
And on that note,
Michael Shermer,
heavens on earth,
the scientific search for the afterlife,
immortality and Utopia available now on
Amazon and everywhere else.
Thanks.
Thank you brother.
Appreciate it,
man.